sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
der 24 februar
2022 markiert eine zeitenwende in der
geschichte unseres kontinents mit dem
überfall auf die ukraine hat der
russische präsident putin kaltblütig ein
angriffskrieg vom zaun gebrochen aus
einem einzigen grund die freiheit der
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer stellt sein
eigenes unterdrückungsregime in frage
das ist menschenverachtend ist
völkerrechtswidrig dass es durch nichts
und niemanden zu rechtfertigen
die schrecklichen bilder aus kiew
odessa und mario pohl zeige die ganze
skrupellosigkeit putins die
himmelschreiende ungerechtigkeit
der schmerz der ukraine noch keiner sie
gehen uns allen sehr nahe
ich weiß genau
welche fragen sich die bürgerinnen und
bürger in diesen tagen abends am
küchentisch
welche sorgen sie umtreiben
angesichts der furchtbaren nachrichten
aus dem krieg
viele von uns haben noch die erzählung
unserer eltern oder großeltern immer vom
krieg
und für die jüngeren ist es kaum fassbar
krieg in europa
viele von ihnen verleihen ihrem
entsetzen aus überall im land hier in
berlin
wir erleben eine zeitenwende
und das bedeutet die welt danach
ist nicht mehr dieselbe wie die welt
davor
im kern geht es um die frage ob macht
das recht brechen darf ob wir es putin
gestatten die uhren zurückzudrehen in
die zeit der großmächte des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts oder ob wir die kraft
aufbringen kriegstreibern wie putin
grenzen zu setzen
das setzt eigene stärke voraus
ja wir wollen und wir werden unsere
freiheit unsere demokratie und unseren
wohlstand sichern und ich bin ihnen frau
präsidentin sehr dankbar dass sich die
vorstellung der bundesregierung dazu
heute in dieser sondersitzung mit dem
teilen kann und auch den vorsitzenden
aller demokratischen fraktionen dieses
hauses danke ich dafür dass sie diese
setzung unterstützt
meine damen und herren mit dem überfall
auf die ukraine will putin nicht nur ein
unabhängiges land von der weltkarte
tilgen er zertrümmert die europäische
sicherheits ordnung wie sie seit der
schlussakte von helsinki
fast ein halbes jahrhundert bestand
hatte er stellt sich auch ins abseits
der gesamten internationalen
staatengemeinschaft
weltweit haben unsere botschaft und in
den vergangenen tagen gemeinsam mit
frankreich dafür geworben die russische
aggression im sicherheitsrat der
vereinten nationen als das zu benennen
dass sie ist ein infamer volker
rechtsbruch und wenn man sich das
ergebnis der sicherheitsratssitzung in
new york anschaut durchaus mit erfolg
die beratung haben gezeigt wir stehen
keineswegs allein in unserem einsatz für
den frieden wir werden den fortsetzen
mit aller kraft dafür was sie dort
zustande gebracht hat bin ich aus
ministerien werbung sehr dankbar
[Applaus]
nur mit der notbremse seines vetos
konnte moskau immerhin ein ständiges
mitglied des sicherheitsrates die eigene
verurteilung verhindern was für eine
schande
präsident putin redet dabei stets von
unteilbaren sicherheit
tatsächlich aber will er gerade den
kontinent mit waffengewalt und
altbekannte einflusssphären teilen
das hat folgen für die sicherheit in
europa
dauerhaft ist sicherheit in europa nicht
gegen russland möglich auf absehbare
zeit aber gefährte putin diese
sicherheit das muss klar ausgesprochen
werden
wir nehmen die herausforderung an vor
der die zeit uns gestellt hat nüchtern
und entschlossen
fünf handlungs aufträge liegen nun vor
uns
erstens wir müssen die ukraine in dieser
verzweifelten lage unterstützen das
haben wir auch in den vergangenen wochen
monaten und jahren in großem umfang
getan aber mit dem überfall auf die
ukraine sind wir in einer neuen zeit in
kiew
odessa und mario pohl verteidigen die
menschen nicht nur ihre heimat sie
kämpfen für freiheit und ihre demokratie
für werte die mit ihnen teilen
[Applaus]
als demokratinnen und demokraten als
europäerinnen und europäer stehen wir an
ihrer seite auf der richtigen seite der
geschichte
am donnerstag hat präsident putin mit
seinem überfall auf die ukraine eine
neue realität geschaffen
diese neue realität erfordert eine klare
antwort wir haben sie gegeben wie sie
wissen haben wir gestern entschieden
dass deutschland der ukraine waffen zur
verteidigung des landes liefern wird
auf dienst adressen konnte es keine
andere antwort geben
meine damen und herren unser zweiter
handlungsauftrag ist putin von seinem
kriegsbuch kurs abzubringen der krieg
ist eine katastrophe für die ukraine
aber der krieg wird sich auch als
katastrophe für russland erweisen
gemeinsam mit den eu und staats und
regierungschefs haben wir ein
sanktionspaket von bisher ungekannten
ausmaß verabschiedet wir schneiden
russische banken und staatsunternehmen
von der finanzierung ab wir verhindern
den export von zukunfts technologie nach
russland wir nehmen die oligarchen und
ihre geldanlagen in der eu ins visier
hinzu kommt die strafmaßnahmen gegen
putin und personen in seinem direkten
umfeld und einschränkungen bei der
visavergabe für russische offizielle
und wir schließen wichtige russische
banken von banken kommunikationsnetz
swift aus darauf haben wir uns gestern
mit den staats und regierungschefs
machen wir uns nichts vor
putin wird seinen kurs nicht über nacht
ändern
doch schon sehr bald wird die russische
führung spüren welch hohen preis bezahlt
allein in der letzten woche haben
russische börsenwert um über 30 prozent
nachgegeben das zeigt unsere sanktionen
wirken und wir behalten uns weitere
sanktionen vor ohne irgendwelche
denkverbote
unsere richtung bleibt die frage was
trifft die verantwortlichen am härtesten
die um die es geht und nicht das
russische volk
wenn putin nicht das russische volk hat
sich für den krieg entschieden
deshalb gehört es deutlich ausgesprochen
dieser krieg ist putins krieg
die differenzierung ist mir wichtig
denn die aussöhnung zwischen deutschen
und russen nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
ist und bleibt ein wichtiges kapitel
unserer gemeinsamen geschichte
und ich weiß wie schwierig zu ertragen
die derzeitige situation gerade für die
vielen bürgerinnen und bürger unseres
landes ist die in der ukraine oder in
russland geboren sind
darum werden wir nicht zulassen dass
dieser konflikt zwischen putin und der
freien welt zum aufreißen alter wunden
und zu neuen verwerfungen führt
und noch etwas sollten wir nicht
vergessen in vielen russischen städten
haben bürgerinnen und bürger in den
vergangenen tagen gegen kurt putins
krieg protestiert haben verhaftung und
bestrafung in kauf genommen das
erfordert
deutschland steht heute an der seite der
ukraine ukraine unsere gedanken und
unser mitgefühl gelten heute den opfern
des russischen angriffskriegs
und genau so stehen der an der seite all
jener in russland die putins
machtapparat mutig die stirn bieten und
seinen krieg gegen die ukraine ablehnen
wir wissen sie sind viele
ihnen allen sage ich geben sie nicht auf
ich bin ganz sicher
freiheit toleranz und menschenrechte
werden sich auch in russland durchsetzen
meine damen und herren die dritte große
herausforderung liegt darin zu
verhindern dass putins krieg auf andere
länder in europa übergreifen
das bedeutet ohne wenn und aber stehen
wir zu unserer beistandspflicht in der
nato
das habe ich auch unseren alliierten in
mittel und osteuropa gesagt die sich um
ihre sicherheit sorgen
präsident putin sollte unsere
entschlossenheit nicht unterschätzen
gemeinsam mit unseren alliierten jeden
quadratmeter des bündnisgebietes zu
verteidigen
wir meinen das sehr ernst mit der
aufnahme eines landes in die nato ist
unser wille als bündnispartner verbunden
dieses land zu verteidigen und zwar so
wie uns selbst
die bundeswehr hat ihre unterstützung
für die östlichen bündnispartner bereits
ausgeweitet und wird es weiter tun für
dieses wichtige signal dank rechter
bundesverteidigungsministerium in
litauen wo wir den einsatz verband der
nato führen haben wir unsere truppe
aufgestockt und sein einsatz beim r
police in rumänien haben wir verlängert
und ausgeweitet
wir wollen uns am aufbau einer neuen
nato einheit in der slowakei beteiligen
unsere marine hilft mit zusätzlichen
schiffen bei der sicherung von nord und
ostsee und im mittelmeer und wir sind
bereit uns mit luftabwehrraketen auch an
der verteidigung des luftraums unserer
alliierten in osteuropa zu beteiligen
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten haben in
den vergangenen tagen oft nur wenig zeit
gehabt sich auf diese einsätze
vorzubereiten
ich sage ihnen und sicher auch in ihrem
namen danke
danke und für ihren wichtigen dienst
gerade in diesen tagen
meine damen und herren angesichts der
zeitenwende die putins aggression
bedeutet lautet unser maßstab was für
die sicherung des friedens in europa
gebraucht wird das wird getan
deutschland wird dazu seinen
solidarischen beitrag leisten
dass heute klar und unmissverständlich
fest zu halten reicht aber nicht aus
denn dafür braucht die bundeswehr neue
starke fähigkeiten
und das ist mein viertes anliegen
und das ist mein viertes anliegen meine
damen und herren
putins historisierende abhandlung liest
wer seine öffentliche kriegserklärung an
die ukraine im fernsehen gesehen hat
oder wer wie ich kürzlich persönlich mit
ihm stundenlang gesprochen hat der kann
kein zweifel mehr haben
putin will ein russisches imperium
richten
er will die verhältnisse in europa nach
seinen vorstellungen grundlegend neu
ordnen und dabei schreckt er nicht
zurück vor militärischer gewalt das
sehen wir heute in der ukraine
wir müssen uns daher fragen welche
fähigkeiten besitzt putins russland
und welche fähigkeiten brauchen wir um
dieser bedrohung zu begegnen heute und
in der zukunft
klar ist wir müssen deutlich mehr
investieren in die sicherheit unseres
landes um auf diese weise unsere
freiheit und unsere demokratie zu
schützen
das ist eine große nationale
kraftanstrengung
das ziel ist eine leistungsfähige
hochmoderne fortschrittliche bundeswehr
die uns zuverlässig schützt
ich habe bei der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz vor einer woche
gesagt wir brauchen flugzeuge die
fliegen schiffe die in see stechen und
soldatinnen soldaten die für ihre
einsätze optimal ausgerüstet sind
darum geht es
und das ist ja wohl erreichbar für ein
land unserer größe und unserer bedeutung
in europa
aber machen wir uns nichts vor bessere
ausrüstungen modernes einsatzgerät mehr
personal das kostet viel geld
wir werden dafür
ein sondervermögen bundeswehr einrichten
und ich bin bundesfinanzminister lindner
sehr dankbar für seine unterstützung
dabei
der bundeshaushalt
2022 wird dieses sondervermögen einmalig
mit 100 milliarden euro ausstatten die
mittel werden der für notwendige
investitionen in brüssel das vorhaben
nutzen
wir werden von nun an jahr für jahr mehr
als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts in unserer partei
nehmen bisher
und
und meine damen und herren ich richte
mich hier an alle fraktionen des
deutschen bundestages
lassen sie uns das sondervermögen im
grundgesetz absichern
eines will ich hinzufügen
wir streben dieses ziel nicht nur an
weil wir bei unseren freunden alliierten
im wort stehen unsere
verteidigungsausgaben bis 2024 auf zwei
prozent unserer wirtschaftsleistung zu
steigern
wir tun dies auch für uns für unsere
eigene sicherheit
wohl wissend dass sich nicht alle
bedrohung der zukunft mit den mitteln
der
bundeswehreinheiten lassen
deshalb brauchen wir eine starke
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
deshalb
es werden wir unsere silieren stark
technisch und gesellschaftlich zb gegen
cyberangriffe und des
informationskampagnen gegen angriffe auf
unsere kritische infrastruktur und
kommunikationswege
und wir werden technologisch auf der
höhe der zeit bleiben
darum ist es mir zum beispiel so wichtig
dass wir die nächste generation von
kampfflugzeugen und panzern gemeinsam
mit europäischen partnern und
insbesondere frankreich hier in europa
bauen diese projekte am oberste
priorität für uns
bis die neuen flugzeuge einsatzbereit
sind wenn wir den eurofighter gemeinsam
weiterentwickeln gut ist auch dass die
verträge zur euro drohne in dieser woche
endlich unterzeichnet werden konnten
auch die anschaffung der bewaffneten
heron drohne aus israel treiben wir
voran
und für die nukleare teilhabe werden wir
rechtzeitig einen modernen ersatz für
die veralteten tornado-jets beschaffen
der eurofighter soll zu electronic
warfare befähigt werden das
kampfflugzeug f 35 kommt als
trägerflugzeug in betracht
und schließlich meine damen und herren
werden wir mehr tun um unsere eine
sichere energieversorgung unseres landes
zu gewährleisten
eine wichtige maßnahme dazu hat die
bundesregierung bereits auf den weg
gebracht und wir werden um steuern um
steuern um unsere importabhängigkeit von
einzelnen energielieferanten zu
überwinden
die ereignisse der letzten tage und
wochen haben uns doch gezeigt eine
verantwortungsvolle vorausschauende
energiepolitik ist nicht nur
entscheidend für unsere wirtschaft und
unser klima
sondern entscheidend auch für unsere
sicherheit
deshalb gilt je schneller wir den ausbau
erneuerbarer energien vorantreiben desto
besser
und wir sind auf dem richtigen weg wir
wollen als industrieland bis 2045 10 und
20 werden
mit diesem ziel vor augen werden wir
wichtige entscheidungen treffen müssen
etwa eine kohle und gas diverse selber
aufzubauen wir haben beschlossen die
speichermenge an erdgas über so genannte
long term auction zum 2 milliarden
kubikmeter zu erhöhen zudem werden wir
rückgekoppelt mit der eu zusätzliches
erdgas auf den weltmärkten erwerbung
und schließlich haben wir die
entscheidung getroffen zwei
flüssiggasterminals lng terminals in
brunsbüttel und wilhelmshaven schnell zu
bauen
bundeswirtschaftsminister habe ich
möchte ich für seinen einsatz dabei ganz
ausdrücklich danken
dass das nun kurzfristig notwendig ist
lässt sich mit dem verbinden was
langfristig ohnehin gebraucht wird für
den erfolg der transformation ein lng
terminal in dem wir heute gas ankommen
lassen kann morgen auch grünen
wasserstoff aufnehmen
und natürlich behalten wir bei alldem
die hohen energiepreise im blick
putins krieg hat sie zuletzt noch weiter
steigen lassen
deshalb haben wir in dieser woche ein
entlastungspaket vereinbart mit der
abschaffung der eeg umlage noch in
diesem jahr eine erhöhung der
pendlerpauschale beim heizkostenzuschuss
für geringverdiener zuschüsse für
familien und steuerlichen entlastung die
bundesregierung wird das schnell auf den
weg bringen
unsere botschaft ist klar wir lassen die
bürgerinnen und bürger und die
unternehmen in dieser lage nicht allein
meine damen und herren die zeitenwende
trifft nicht nur unser land sie trifft
ganz europa und auch darin stecken
herausforderung und chance zugleich
die herausforderung besteht darin die
souveränität der europäischen union
nachhaltig und dauerhaft zu stärken die
chance liegt darin dass wir die
geschlossenheit waren die wir in den
letzten tagen unter beweis gestellt
haben stichwort sanktionspaket
für deutschland und für alle anderen
mitgliedsländer der eu heißt das nicht
bloß zu fragen was man für das eigene
land in brüssel herausführen kann
sondern zu fragen was ist das beste was
ist die beste entscheidung für die union
europa ist unser handlungsrahmen nur
wenn wir das begreifen werden wir vor
den herausforderungen unserer zeit
bestehen
und damit mir nicht beim fünften und
letzten punkt
wo dienst krieg bedeutet eine zäsur auch
für unsere außenpolitik
so viel diplomatie wie möglich ohne naiv
zu sein dieser anspruch
nicht naiv zu sein das bedeutet aber
auch kein reden um des redens linz für
echten dialog braucht es die
bereitschaft dazu auf beiden seiten
daran mangelt es auf seiten putins ganz
offensichtlich und das nicht erst in den
letzten tagen und wochen
das heißt das für die zukunft
wir werden uns gesprächen mit russland
nicht verweigern auch in dieser extremen
lage ist es die aufgabe der diplomatie
gesprächskanäle offen zu halten
alles andere halte ich für
unverantwortlich
meine damen und herren wir wissen wofür
wir einstehen auch angesichts unserer
eigenen geschichte wir stehen ein für
den frieden in europa
wir werden uns nie abfinden mit gewalt
als mittel der politik wir werden uns
immer stark machen wird es die
friedliche lösung von konflikten und wir
werden nicht ruhen bis der frieden in
europa gesichert ist
und dabei stehen wir nicht allein
sondern zusammen mit unseren freunden
und partnern in europa und weltweit
unsere größte stärke sind unsere
bündnisse und allianzen ihnen verdanken
wir das große glück dass unser land seit
über 30 jahren genießt in einem
vereinten land zu leben in wohlstand und
frieden mit unseren nachbarn
wenn wir wollen dass diese letzten 30
jahre keine historische ausnahme bleiben
dann müssen wir alles tun für den
zusammenhalt der europäischen union für
die stärke der nato für noch engere
beziehung zu unseren freunden partnern
und gleichgesinnten weltweit ich bin
voller zuversicht dass uns das gelingt
denn selten waren wir und unsere partner
so entschlossen und so geschlossen
uns eint in diesen tagen wir wissen um
die stärke freierer demokratie wir
wissen was von einem breiten
gesellschaftlichen und politischen
konsens getragen wird das hat bestand
auch in dieser zeitenwende und darüber
hinaus
und deshalb danke ich ihnen und allen
fraktionen dieses hauses die den
russischen überfall auf die ukraine
entschieden als das verurteilt haben was
er ist ein durch nichts zu
rechtfertigender angriff auf ein
unabhängiges land auf die
friedensordnung in europa und in der
welt der heutige entschließungsantrag
bringt das klar zum ausdruck
ich danke allen die in diesen tagen
zeichen setzen gegen putins krieg und
die sich hier in berlin und anderswo zu
friedlichen kundgebungen versammeln
und ich danke allen die in diesen zeiten
mit uns einstehen für ein freies und
offenes gerechtes und friedliches europa
wir werden das verteidigen
[Applaus]
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler sie
müssten ihre maske wieder aussetzen
vielen dank ich eröffne die aussprache
und als erster hat das wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion friedrich merz
frau präsidentin
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
dieser
24 september
wird uns allen als einen tag im
gedächtnis bleiben von dem wir später
einmal sagen werden
ich weiß noch genau wo ich war
als ich die erste nachricht vom krieg in
der ukraine gehört und die ersten bilder
davon gesehen habe
unsere ersten gedanken in diesen minuten
gehalten und sie gelten unverändert bis
heute dem ganzen volk der ukraine
wir trauern mit den familien um die
opfer
dieses bis heute und auch in diesen
stunden und den minuten in so großer
zahl auch unter der zivilbevölkerung
gibt und wir bewundern den mut
und den willen dieses volkes um seine
freiheit zu kämpfen
wir sind zugleich beschämt und bedrückt
dass wir diesem land und diesem volk
nicht schon haben früher helfen können
und wohl größten behinderungen und unser
größter respekt gilt dem frei gewählten
staatspräsidenten der ukraine präsident
wolodimir zielinski
diesen diesen mutigen mann der aus einer
jüdischen familie stammt als
drogenabhängig und als nazi zu
diffamieren wie ist der russische
präsident in dieser woche getan hat
zeigt ein ausmaß an niedertracht und
menschenverachtung wie wir es in den
letzten jahrzehnten auf diesem kontinent
nicht erlebt habe
also das ganze sie haben es so
ausgedrückt mit diesem krieg geht eine
zeitepoche in europa zu ende eine zeit
von der wir erhofft und geglaubt haben
dass sie in frieden und in freiheit und
natürlich auch im wohlstand im ganzen
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
voranschreitet seit wenigen tagen sind
wir nun eines besseren belehrt
brutal und rücksichtslos
hat ein autoritäres system ein
angriffskrieg mitten in europa bekommen
ja mitten in europa denn dieser krieg
für den stadt zwischen den beiden
territorial größten ländern europas
russland sein europäisches land und die
ukraine ist ein europäisches land der
krieg findet statt weniger als zwei
flugstunden von diesem ort aus dem wir
uns heute morgen an einem sonntag
treffen herr bundeskanzler ich möchte
ihnen im namen der unionsfraktion und
der sie tragenden parteien cdu und csu
danken für ihre regierungserklärung
sie wissen
wie wissen
dass wir sehr darum bemüht sind mit
ihnen und den sie tragenden
koalitionsfraktionen einen gemeinsamen
weg in dieser zeit einer großen
herausforderung zu geben wir haben in
den letzten tagen mit ihren
fraktionen um gemeinsame antworten
gerungen und wir geben sie wieder in
einem entschließungsantrag den wir heute
gemeinsam mit der spd den grünen und der
fdp
einbringen aber lassen sie mich das ganz
deutlich sagen dieser antrag ist nur das
gemeinsame minimum das wir heute hier
feststellen können wir haben und wir
behalten hoffentlich auch in der zukunft
eine klare auffassung zu diesem krieg
und seinem einzigen verantwortlichen der
verantwortliche mann heißt wladimir
putin
auch stiefel aus diesem lupenreinen
demokraten der er nie war ist nun
endgültig und für alle welt sichtbar ein
kriegsverbrecher geworden
aber so ein krieg
gefehlt nicht einer allein und er
entsteht auch nicht ohne ein politisches
umfeld
das verantwortliche system um ihn herum
ist ein geflecht von
geheimdienstoffizieren und erprobten
meistern der politischen propaganda wie
etwa sein außenminister lawrow auf ein
geflecht einer großen gruppe
hemmungsloser oligarchen die sich die
ressourcen dieses landes unter den nagel
gerissen haben und vor allem aus einem
repressiven staatsapparat der ohne jeden
anflug von rechtsstaatlichkeit beliebig
verhaftet vergiftet im lager steckt
familien zerstört und auch nicht davor
zurückschreckt mitten in den ländern
westeuropas
auftragsmorde zufolge stecken
und damit an dieser stelle und meine
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen überhaupt kein missverständnis
entsteht die verantwortlichkeit liegt
allein dort und allein bei diesen
handelnden akteuren aber zu diesem
netzwerk zählen seit vielen jahren auch
mehr oder weniger gutgläubige
interessenvertreter in aller welt auch
und gerade hier in deutschland die sich
einmal als putin versteher gerieren das
andere mal als freunde russlands die bis
hin zu windigen
stiftungskonstruktionen nichts
unversucht lassen nichts unversucht
lassen
mit diesem system
mit diesem system geschäfte zu machen
und das ganze dann auch noch zu
versuchen der öffentlichkeit als
gemeinnützig zu vermitteln sie als
nützliche idioten ganz im sinne der
linien denkmuster zu bezeichnen ist dann
wohl noch die freundlichste umschreibung
dieses treibens auf dem gerade hier in
deutschland
die bedrohung der ukraine durch einen
angriffskrieg ist aber nicht die einzige
bedrohung die wir in diesen tagen sehen
parallel zu den panzer rollen seit
jahren wenden von propaganda durch
europa die in zeiten der digitalisierung
und der sozialen netzwerke eine hohe
effizienz und damit einen großen schaden
erzeugen ein schaden der auch unsere
gesellschaftliche ordnung von ihnen
bedroht meine damen und herren dieser
propaganda
zu dieser propaganda zählt seit langem
die behauptung die nato sei der
eigentliche aggressor gegen das
friedliebende russland dies ist in der
tat großartige land müsse sich nun so
der allmächtige staatsapparat und sein
präsident gegen eine militärische
bedrohung zur wehr setzen dabei wissen
sie es alle besser herr putin auch sie
sind und waren von der nato nie bedroht
das wissen sie auch das wissen sie
meine damen und herren wenn sie von
dieser stelle aus sehen wer jetzt
klatscht und wer jetzt nicht klappt dann
weiß ich welche reden geben verlaufe des
heutigen vormittags hier noch zu hören
bekommen von ganz links und von ganz
rechts auf dieser seite
das wissen wir jetzt schon hier
anzuschauen die sie dann hier gleich
sprechen werden aber meine damen und
herren die einzige die einzige bedrohung
dies für putin und seine nomenklatura
gibt die einzige bedrohung und die nimmt
er zu recht sehr ernst ist die bedrohung
seiner macht durch das eigene volk die
bedrohung durch freiheit und demokratie
auch in seiner nachbarschaft da ist die
bedrohung für dieses system und deshalb
und deshalb unterdrückt putin im eigenen
land jede opposition und deshalb macht
der gemeinsame sache mit alexander
lukaschenko der heute an diesem tag hier
während wir hier zusammen treten ein
sogenanntes referendum in belarus
abhalten lassen um die verfassung zu
ändern und ab dem morgigen tag in diesem
land auch atomwaffen stationieren zu
können meine damen und herren das ist
die neue realität in der wir in dieser
woche aufgewacht sind die
staatengemeinschaft des westens
die europäer die amerikaner viele andere
länder auf der welt reagieren auf diesen
bruch des völkerrechts und aller
verträge die wir mit russland bisher
gemacht haben mit konsequenz und härte
russland wird international isoliert das
land und seine repräsentanten werden
auch persönlich sanktioniert dazu gehört
damit dass hier kreist auch von meiner
seite richtigerweise swift das
internationale zahlungssystem mit dem
jetzt russland aus dem internationalen
zahlungsverkehr ausgeschlossen
der bundeskanzler
herr bundeskanzler herzlichen dank dass
sie das heute morgen hier gesagt haben
dass sie in den letzten tagen darüber
intensive gespräche und verhandlungen
geführt haben einschließlich auch der
frage wie denn mit waffenlieferungen aus
mehreren europäischen ländern nach in
die ukraine jetzt umzugehen ist wichtig
ist das klare und unmissverständliche
signal vom heutigen tag genug ist genug
das spiel ist aus
lassen nämlich aber auch sehr deutlich
sagen gefragt sind jetzt nicht gute
reden am heutigen tag alle gefragt sind
und gute regierungserklärung ja liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen eine gute
regierung cent werden gefragt sind
stringenz und durchhaltevermögen in den
nächsten tagen und wochen denn dieses
durchhaltevermögen kann schon in wenigen
tagen auf harte proben gestellt werden
die sanktionen werden wirkung entfalten
nicht nur in russland sondern auch hier
bei uns
der krieg in der ukraine wird
konsequenzen fordern nicht nur in der
verteidigungspolitik sondern auch in
vielen anderen bereichen
und deshalb herr bundeskanzler bieten
wir ihnen heute an dieser stelle ihnen
und ihrer regierung umfassende konkrete
hilfe und unterstützung an wenn sie um
unterstützung und zustimmung für die
jetzt notwendigen umfassenden sanktionen
werben und sie tun es ja heute morgen
dann werden wir das unterstützen und
nicht im kleinen herummäkeln wenn sie
eine umfassende
wenn sie eine umfassende ertüchtigung
unserer streitkräfte wollen und wir
wollen sie ganz offensichtlich ab heute
mit ihnen dann werden wir auch gegen
widerstände diesen weg mit ihnen gehen
wenn sie es für notwendig erachten die
energiepolitik und die ihrer regierung
neu auszurichten wenn sie mit uns der
meinung sind dass wir jetzt endgültig
auf keine weiteren optionen der
energieerzeugung mehr verzichten dürfen
dann finden sie dabei unsere tatkräftige
unterstützung
und wenn sie
wenn sie es so wollen wie sie das heute
morgen hier vorschlagen dann können wir
auch darüber der bundeskanzler reden
aber ein sondervermögen ist nicht ein
vermögen sondern ein sondervermögen sind
zunächst einmal neue schulden und wie
wir diese neuen schulden aufnehmen und
wie wir sie dann möglicherweise in
unserer verfassung verankern das geht
nicht allein mit einer
regierungserklärung am sonntagmorgen zu
machen darüber müssen wir dann in ruhe
und im detail sprechen
und lassen nämlich auch dies ganz klar
sagen lassen sie mich hier dies ganz
klar sagen das machen wir dann in allen
teilen gemeinsam nicht in der
arbeitsteilung dass wir mit ihnen für
die unangenehmen dinge den kopf
hinhalten und sie in ihrer koalition
dann unverändert weiter alle wohltaten
zu lasten der jungen generation
verteilen herr bundeskanzler hat das
machen wir dann pflicht
aber
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen das sind ja alles die mehr
oder weniger nahe liegenden
entscheidungen die wir jetzt kurzfristig
treffen müssen die eigentliche
herausforderung ist doch eine ganz
andere und sie liegt viel tiefer in
wahrheit stehen wir spätestens mit
dieser woche vor einem scherbenhaufen
der deutschen und europäischen außen-
und sicherheitspolitik der letzten jahre
und jahrzehnte
einige der einige der vermeintlichen
gewissheiten
einige der vermeintlichen gewissheiten
der letzten jahre gehören nun endgültig
der vergangenheit an wir sind nicht mehr
nur von freunden umgeben auch wir werden
durch einen aggressiven start in unserer
direkten nachbarschaft
bedroht einseitige abrüstung führt nicht
zu mehr sondern zu weniger sicherheit
oder hatte und hausführungen thema
oder hat hier im haus irgend jemand
vergessen dass die ukraine 1994 alle
ihre atomwaffen abgegeben hat und im
gegenzug dazu von russland umfassende
und dauerhafte garantien der
territorialen integrität erhalten hat
man damit hat dass irgendjemand von
ihnen hier vergessen
und lassen sie mich das so sagen
lichterketten friedensgebete
ostermärsche sind eine schöne sache auch
wir haben heute morgen mit einer reihe
von abgeordneten aus dem deutschen
bundestag
auch wir haben heute morgen
auch wir haben heute morgen mit einer
gruppe von abgeordneten aus dem
deutschen bundestag und einigen
fraktionen um den frieden in der welt
gebetet und um das ende dieses krieges
gebetet aber meine damen und herren mit
moral allein wird die welt um uns drum
herum nicht friedlich schon gar nicht
mit der angeblich besseren moral die
immer wieder auch in deutschland
vorgetragen wird
der ukraine der ukraine jedenfalls haben
gute worte nichts genutzt auch nicht die
vertagte mitgliedschaft in der nato
meine damen und schließlich auch
deutschland muss endlich bereit sein in
dieser welt seine interessen zu
definieren und vor allem bereit seien
vor allem bereit sein diese interessen
auch durchzusetzen
dazu zählt nicht nur aber auch die
fähigkeit das eigene territorium und die
eigene bevölkerung wirksam gegen jedwede
form der gewalt und der nötigung zu
schützen und zu verteidigen
die bundeswehr ist dort wo sie gefragt
ist die bundeswehr ist dazu soweit sie
gefragt ist heute am tag jedenfalls
nicht in der lage
das sind
das sind also wenn da reagiere ich nicht
aber hier reagiere ich schon wenn sie
das zu einem thema der parteipolitischen
auseinandersetzung machen
was wir was wir waren damen und herren
wir
sind in diesem haus und ich war schon
ziemlich früh dabei wir sind in diesem
haus aller miteinander verantwortlich
dafür dass die bundeswehr in dem zustand
ist in dem sie heute ist wir haben uns
bemüht wir haben uns bemüht das zu
verbessern vieles ist an ihnen
gescheitert wenn wir heute einen neuen
weg nach vorn gehen dann gehen wir ihn
gemeinsam aber nur dann wenn wir ihn
jetzt wirklich gemeinsam nach vorn geht
und nicht wenn sie hier parteipolitisch
zurückblicken
das sind
das sind alles
ja das sind alles andere
das sind alles annahmen und politische
einschätzungen die sie hier im hause
teilen mögen oder auch nicht aber die
eigentliche
führungsaufgabe kommt in diesem
historischen augenblick so oder so auf
sie zu herr bundeskanzler lassen nämlich
deswegen abschließend lassen sie mich
deswegen abschließend aus einer großen
deutschen tageszeitung zitieren dies vor
einigen tagen aus meiner sicht sehr
präzise auf den punkt gebracht hat der
autor schreibt am wochenende einer sehr
ernüchternden analyse wie folgt die
eigentliche rechnung aber wird in
deutschland selbst fällig wo diesen
krisen dichte auf eine weitgehend
unvorbereitete bevölkerung trifft der
schlicht das handwerkszeug fehlt um mit
erpressung nötigung militärischer
bedrohung auf das politische system
umzugehen
unsicherheit so schreibt er weiter
entsteht in der regel durch einen
aggressor aber gefährlich wird sie erst
durch schwäche ende des titels das
notwendige handwerkszeug herr
bundeskanzler
diese schwäche in unserem land zu
beseitigen
dieses notwendige handwerkszeug ist seit
dieser woche die historische aufgabe
ihrer kanzlerschaft herzlichen dank für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
nächste rednerin für die bundesregierung
die bundesministerin annalena baerbock
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen liebe mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger die bilder aus der ukraine
sind kaum zu ertragen
tausende fliehen wahrscheinlich jeder
hier im saal hat eine nachricht bekommen
von freunden bekannten von kolleginnen
und kollegen mit dem man so wie ich
letzte woche noch gemeinsam in kiew
mittag gegessen hat die jetzt sagen
'bitte rettet uns eltern mit kleinen
kindern verbringen in u-bahn-schächten
ihre nächte um schutz vor bomben und
raketen zu suchen das könnten wir in
diesen bahn schächten sein dass könnten
unsere kinder sein was wir gerade mitten
in europa passiert war für jemand aus
meiner generation bisher unvorstellbar
es ist der moment in dem der
angriffskrieg nach europa zurück
gekommen ist
unsere welt ist nach diesem
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg von
putin jetzt eine andere
botschaft wenig ich begrüße sie hier im
seiten stellvertretend für die über 40
millionen mutigen ukrainerinnen und
ukraine
[Applaus]
ich möchte ihnen hier aus ganzem herzen
sagen das unsägliche leid der männer
frauen und kinder trifft uns ins mark
wir sind fassungslos angesichts dessen
was der ukraine was den menschen in der
ukraine erneut angetan wird aber wir
sind nicht ohnmächtig wir lassen sie in
dieser rücksichtslosen aggression auf
gelangt nicht alleine
dieser krieg ist kein krieg der menschen
in russland
dieser krieg ist putins krieg
dieser krieg ist ein angriff auf unseren
frieden in europa dieser krieg ist ein
angriff auf unsere freiheit dieser krieg
ist ein angriff auf das internationale
völkerrecht dieser krieg ist ein angriff
auf all die werte einer regelbasierten
internationalen ordnung und dieser krieg
ist ein angriff auf das menschliche
friedliche miteinander
und es ist ein krieg der es nötig macht
dass wir die grundfesten unseres
außenpolitischen handelns 19 vor wenigen
wochen noch habe ich hier in diesem saal
zum thema waffenlieferungen gesagt dass
man seine außenpolitische
180 grad wendung im richtigen moment und
bei vollem bewusstsein treffen muss
jetzt ist so traurig es ist der moment
dafür wir haben es bis zuletzt zur
letzten minute mit diplomatie versucht
der kreml hat uns hingehalten belogen
und sich all dem verweigert wofür wir
bisher als europäerinnen und europäer
eingestanden haben putin wollte diesen
krieg whatever it takes
russland hat die ukraine rücksichtslos
angegriffen und die ukraine hat wie
jedes land dieser welt ein recht auf
selbstverteidigung verbrieft in der
charta der vereinten nationen
und wir die auf dem boden das
völkerrecht stehen stehen auch in der
pflicht diese charta der vereinten
nationen jetzt gemeinsam zu verteidigen
vielleicht ist es so
dass deutschland am heutigen tag eine
form besonderer und alleinstehender
zurückhaltung in der außen und
sicherheitspolitik hinter sich zuletzt
die regeln die wir uns dafür gegeben
haben dürfen uns nicht aus unserer
verantwortung nehmen wenn unsere welt
ein andere ist dann muss auch unsere
politik eine andere sein
ein land mit einer parlamentsarmee und
umfassender demokratischer kontrolle
darf und muss sich erlauben und das tun
wir mit dem heutigen tag in fragen von
krieg und frieden in voller
verantwortung zu entscheiden
wir werden bei waffenexporten und
einsetzen weiter aus tiefster
überzeugung zurückhaltend sein wir
werden uns aber in dieser historischen
stunde
angesichts des brutalen angriffs auf die
ukraine für eine unterstützung
entscheiden die neben unserem großen
wirtschaftlichen und humanitären
engagement die ukraine jetzt auch mit
lieferung von militärischen material und
waffen unterstützt
weil wir dürfen die ukraine nicht
wehrlos dem aggressor überlassen der tod
und verwüstung über dieses land bringt
und ich sage ihnen alle sehr wie auch
der bundeskanzler das ist die stärke
dieses wohnhauses das ist die stärke
unserer liberalen demokratie dass ihr
bei sachfragen streiten können erbittert
aber dass wir in dem moment wo es darum
geht unsere grundwerte zu verteidigen
alle
fraktionsübergreifend beieinanderstehen
herzlichen dank
wir tun das weil es hier um
menschenleben geht wir tun das weil
unsere internationale ordnung auf dem
spiel steht wir tun dies mit
besonnenheit und aus verantwortung um
unseren frieden in europa und das ist
auch eine klare botschaft an ladung ja
putin das preisschild dieses krieges
gegen unschuldige menschen oder bruch
mit der charta der vereinten nationen
wird für das system putin und tragbar
seien
wir müssen und das hat der bundeskanzler
unterstrichen jetzt vieles gleichzeitig
tun wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die
menschen in der ukraine schnell mit dem
nötigsten versorgt werden mit
medizinischen gütern mit sicheren
unterkünften
dafür haben wir unter anderem unserem
beitrag zum humanitären
hilfe für die ukraine um 5 millionen
aufgestockt wir stellen für das
internationale komitee des roten kreuzes
weitere hilfe in höhe von zehn millionen
euro kurzfristig bereit wir werden uns
mit allem was wir da haben gemeinsam
dafür einsetzen dass die menschen die
jetzt liegen alle alle in sicherheit
kommen und dafür haben wir
vorbereitungen getroffen und auch das
ist unsere stärke nicht nur in der
europäischen union sondern gemeinsam mit
unseren freunden in kanada in amerika
und an vielen vielen anderen orten in
der welt wir lassen die fliehenden
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer nicht im
stich
und ja auch an dieser stelle müssen wir
über geld reden und ich bitte um die
unterstützung im vorausschauenden
haushalt eben diese humanitäre hilfe
dann auch so auszustatten wie wir das
für den schutz der menschen rauchen
drei weitere elemente sind entscheidend
erstens sanktionen und die bittere
realität ist keine sanktionen kann
diesen waren in diesem moment stoppen
wir hätten wenn wir ein sanktionsmittel
hätte dass alle stopp natürlich dieses
längst ergriffen aber was unsere
sanktionen leisten und das ist zentral
ist putin zu zeigen mittel und
langfristig wird dieser krieg ihr land
ruiniert putins perfides spiel ist auf
strecke angelegt deswegen müssen das auf
unsere sanktionen seien und deswegen
müssen wir so sicherstellen dass uns
nicht nach drei monaten die puste
ausgeht sondern diese sanktionen müssen
das system putin im kern treffen
deswegen
deswegen gehen sie hand in hand
wirtschaftlich finanziell und
individuell deswegen listen wir herrn
putin selbst und den außenminister
lavrov sie tragen verantwortung für
diesen krieg und deswegen werden wir
weitere sanktionen auf den weg bringen
mit blick auf banken oligarchen und
familienangehörige und deswegen haben
wir swift und ich kann verstehen dass da
einige etwas nervös geworden sind aber
ich bitte in diesen zeiten um vertrauen
deswegen haben wir es wirft so angelegt
dass sie das system putin treffen und
nicht als bumerang auf uns zurück kommen
und das gemeinsam mit der
internationalen verantwortung die wir
jetzt gemeinsam zeigen
wir unterstützen unsere bündnispartner
im namen der rat nato das hat der
bundeskanzler bereits deutlich gemacht
die nato ist der garant für unsere
sicherheit und freiheit dafür wurde sie
gegründet und daran hat sich nichts
verändert
und mein letzter punkt ja wir müssen
härte zeigen aber wir stehen hier führt
das internationale recht und china zu
internationalen regeln ein deswegen
gehört in diesem moment der dialog immer
mit dazu nicht mit dem aggressor sondern
mit der internationalen gemeinschaft das
muss jetzt unser absoluter fokus sein es
geht hier nicht nur um europa kein land
der welt kann akzeptieren dass seine
souveränität zur disposition steht wenn
sein stärkerer nachbar es will
dann hätte putin gewonnen deswegen
müssen wir uns jetzt gemeinsam mit allen
staaten die wie wir an die charta der
vereinten nationen glauben dieser
aggression entgegen stellen deswegen
appelliere ich auch hier an all unsere
partner weltweit hier aus diesem
geschichtsträchtigen hohen haus bekennen
sie nächste woche farbe in der
generalversammlung der vereinten
nationen dass es unsere internationale
friedensordnung wir müssen sie jetzt
gemeinsam verteidigen
bei der wahl zwischen krieg und frieden
bei der wahl zwischen einem aggressor
und kindern auf der anderen seite die
sich in u bahn schächten verstecken da
kann niemand neutral sein danke dass wir
das heute hier gemeinsam deutlich machen
die nächste rednerin für die fdp
fraktion spricht von der trimmy tribüne
frau dr alice weidl
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren
russlands angriffskrieg auf ein
nachbarland ist ein rückruf in die raue
welt der realpolitik das ukrainische
volk zahlt den preis für den russischen
völker rechtsbruch für die illusion der
eigenen führung um für die falschen
versprechungen des westens
es war ein verhängnisvoller fehler die
ukraine mit den unerfüllbaren
versprechen einer mitgliedschaft in nato
und eu in eine aussichtslose
konfrontation und eine gefährliche
zerreißprobe zu locken klüger
klüger wäre es gewesen auf henry
kissinger zu hören der schon 2014
richtig festgestellt hat ich zitiere um
zu überleben und sich zu entwickeln darf
die ukraine niemandes vorposten sein
zitat ende das eine nato mitgliedschaft
der ukraine eine rote linie darstellt
deren überschreiten russland nicht
hinnehmen würde wie die vorangegangenen
nato aus erweiterungsrunden liegt seit
fast zwei jahrzehnten klar auf dem tisch
unzählige gelegenheiten wurden seither
versäumt einen status gesicherter
neutralität für die ukraine auszuhandeln
der den sicherheitsinteressen aller
rechnungen getragen und der ukraine
ermöglicht hätte vom zankapfel zu einer
brücke zwischen ost und west zu werden
stattdessen haben die hardliner gefangen
in einer völlig überkommenen logik des
kalten krieges star an der
beitrittsperspektive für die ukraine
festgehalten und dabei überheblich
russland den großmacht status
abgesprochen das ist das historische
versagen des westens die kränkung
russlands es ändert nichts an der
verwerflichkeit des russischen einmarsch
aber das verständnis aller ursachen ist
voraussetzung für die suche nach
lösungen
deutschland hat in seinem gegenwärtigen
zustand nicht aufzubieten um den worten
auch taten folgen zu lassen
sanktionen die den eigenen bürgern am
ende mehr schaden zufügen als denen die
damit gemeint sind werden dem krieg in
der ukraine kein ende setzen können sie
sind letztendlich alibi und
sanktionspolitik sowie das anstrahlen
des brandenburger tores in den
ukrainischen nationalfarben die
gescheiterte energiewende sehr geehrte
damen und herren hat uns in eine fatale
einseitige abhängigkeit von russischen
erdgaslieferungen geführt die
kurzfristig wenn überhaupt nur zu
astronomischen kosten gelöst werden kann
wer erklärt wir seien bereit dafür auch
einen hohen wirtschaftlichen preis zu
zahlen muss auch sagen es ist die
bevölkerung die diesen preis zu zahlen
hat
es hat im übrigen auch gründe dass die
usa nicht daran denken auf ihre
beträchtlichen öl importe aus russland
zu verzichten
sicherheitspolitisch ist deutschland
ebenfalls ein leichtgewicht geworden die
bundeswehr steht blank da besteht sogar
der inspektor des heeres in selten
gewordener offenheit ein eine
heruntergewirtschaftete armee und eine
marginalisierte rüstungsindustrie das
ist das erbe von 16 jahren
gela merkel herr merz
wer soll uns noch ernst nehmen wenn wir
uns wirtschaftlich und militärisch das
rückgrat brechen und uns statt mit
realen problemen mit gender gaga und
ideologischen experimenten dort
beschäftigen das ist grober unfug
wir müssen den weckruf der realpolitik
hören wir brauchen energie politik die
den fokus auf unabhängigkeit und
versorgungssicherheit liegt der
schlüssel dazu sind weder noch mehr
windräder noch flüssiggas aus den usa
sondern der wiedereinstieg in die
friedliche nutzung der kernenergie wie
denn auch sonst
wir brauchen
eine bundeswehr die die fähigkeit zur
landesverteidigung zurückgewinnt das
erfordert nicht allein mehr geld sondern
vor allem eine strategische wende sehr
geehrte damen und herren und wir
brauchen geopolitische nüchternheit
stadt feministischer aussenpolitik
haltung
haltung und schöne worte sind kein
ersatz für realpolitik und noch nach
diesen krieg werden wir mit russland
immer noch auf einem kontinent leben die
herausforderung eine europäische
sicherheitsarchitektur zu schaffen die
das ost west blockdenken überwindet ist
nicht vom tisch aber sie ist schwieriger
geworden
deutschland kann und sollte hier eine
wichtige rolle als ehrlicher makler
spielen voraussetzung ist dass wir die
richtigen konsequenzen ziehen und
verlorenes vertrauen souveränität und
handlungsfreiheit wieder aufbauen und
uns bloß nicht unreflektiert in einen
krieg hineinziehen lassen sehr geehrte
damen und herren ich bedanke mich
nächster redner für die bundesregierung
der bundesminister christian lindner
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
es ist krieg in europa
was geschichte wahr ist gegen wörz
gewonnen
es ist krieg in europa der 24 februar
trends das vorher vom nachher
es reicht nicht mehr
über freiheit und die werte des
grundgesetzes über internationale
zusammenarbeit und solidarität zu reden
jetzt ist die zeit die werte des
grundgesetzes
freiheit und internationale solidarität
zu leben
russland hat einen völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine begonnen
das ist das ende aller hoffnung auf
frieden und es ist auch das ende aller
illusionen über putins russland in
dieser zeit der entscheidung ist
klarheit gefordert wo wir stehen wir
stehen in solidarität an der seite der
ukraine
was haben wir hier gerade gehört
was für ein bild der gründe warum es zu
diesen krieg gekommen ist
sagen wir es in aller klarheit
zu ziehen hat die ukraine angegriffen
weil sich ein souveräner staat
in freier selbstbestimmung
dafür entschieden hat seinen weg nach
westen zu gehen
die ukraine ist ein souveräner staat
und sie hat von ihrem recht gebrauch
gemacht über ihre zukunft zu entscheiden
und sie hat sich gegen autoritative muss
entschieden sie hat sich für demokratie
und rechtsstaatlichkeit entschieden dass
sie angetroffen worden
der angriff auf die ukraine ist deshalb
nicht nur der überfall auf einen
souveränen staat es ist ein angriff auf
eine werteordnung es ist ein angriff auf
uns alle
wir waren uns sind solidarisch mit der
ukraine gemeinsam mit unseren partnern
in der europäischen union und im kreise
der g 7 deutschland hat in der
vergangenheit erhebliche finanzielle
mittel bereitgestellt zur unterstützung
der ukraine und das werden wir
fortsetzen schon in dieser woche werden
wir im kreis der g 7 staaten beraten was
an zusätzlicher hilfe nötig ist wir sind
aber zugleich auch entschlossen
wir ziehen diejenigen mit den mitteln
des rechts zur rechenschaft
die verantwortung dafür tragen dass das
völkerrecht gebrochen wurde wir werden
russland isolieren
wirtschaftlich finanziell und politisch
wir treffen
wir treten russlands banken wir treffen
russlands oligarchen wir treffen
russlands wirtschaft diese aktionen wie
wir beschlossen haben diese sanktionen
sind auf dauer angelegt wir brauchen
einen langen atem
wir haben diesen langen atem
diese sanktionen werden negative
auswirkungen auch auf uns haben aber wir
sind bereit diese negativen auswirkungen
zu tragen denn sie sind der preis der
freiheit
die bundesregierung unternimmt alles um
maximalen druck auf putin auszuüben und
zugleich eine schwäche und unserer
position zu begrenzen
erstens wir haben
sorgfältig unter federführung des
kanzleramts an finanziellen sanktionen
gearbeitet die putin keinen vorwand
biete
notwendige rohstofflieferungen
auszusetzen die auf der anderen seite
aber erreichen dass es mit russland
wortwörtlich kein business as usual mehr
geben wird
damit
und damit enden wir nicht die deutschen
und europäischen finanzbehörden wir
werden alles unternehmen um
geldströme und
vermögenswerte derjenigen die putin
unterstützen zu identifizieren und
einzufrieren
zweitens
wir werden reserven bei gas und kohle
aufbauen um unsere
durchhaltefähigkeit auszubauen dafür
haben wir mittel im milliardenbereich
eingeplant
drittens die bedeutung der
energiesicherheit
erfährt eine neue priorität
unsere planungen der nächsten jahre
werden wir an die veränderte lage
anpassen müssen dabei werden wir nicht
setzen auf die antworten der
vergangenheit sondern im gegenteil den
weg in die zukunft entschlossener
fortsetzen erneuerbare energien läuft
nämlich nicht nur einen beitrag
zur energiesicherheit und versorgung
erneuerbare energien lösen uns von
abhängigkeiten erneuerbare energien sind
deshalb frei heizenergie
wir setzen auch freiheits energie
viertens
die stabilität der öffentlichen finanzen
und die handlungsfähigkeit des staates
müssen erhalten bleiben
die schuldenbremse gilt
das vertrauen der internationalen
kapitalmärkte in deutschland begründet
eine unserer stärken
und fünftens die
anstrengungen die vor uns liegen sind
enorm die anstrengungen die vor uns
liegen erfordern wirtschaftliche stärke
und deshalb ist auch eine konsequenz aus
der veränderten geopolitische lage dass
wir unsere eigene wirtschaftliche
substanz stärken und alles unterlassen
was diese wirtschaftliche stärke
reduziert
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
[Applaus]
wir haben viele jahre eine
friedensdividende genutzt
die bundeswehr wurde vernachlässigt
in diesen tagen wurde noch über eine
taxonomie gesprochen die investitionen
in
verteidigungsfähigkeit eingeschränkt
hätte
der krieg in der ukraine
weckt uns alle aus einem
selbstgerechten traum
die zeit der vernachlässigung der
bundeswehr muss enden
wir werden deshalb in der laufenden
finanzplanung und in jedem haushaltsjahr
die mittel für den verteidigungshaushalt
erhöhen
wir werden den laufenden betrieb der
bundeswehr
werden den laufenden betrieb der
bundeswehr aus den laufenden haushalten
unter achtung der schuldenbremse
finanzieren aber eine jahrelange
mindestens 15 jahre dauernde
vernachlässigung der bundeswehr
kann man nicht von jetzt auf gleich im
laufenden haushalts korrigieren und
deshalb
und sie deshalb müssen wir zu einem
anderen mittel greifen in die bundeswehr
tüchtig
notwendiges material um notwendige
technik anzuschaffen werden wir der
bundeskanzler hat es gesagt ein
sondervermögen einrichten
100 milliarden euro wollen wir dafür zur
verfügung stellen wir wollen dieses
sondervermögen im grundgesetz absichern
um deutlich zu machen dass die
verwendung nur und ausschließlich für
die stärkung unserer bündnisfähigkeit
gedacht ist dafür brauchen wir die
unterstützung der länder dafür brauchen
wir die unterstützung der cdu csu
friedrich merz wir werden nicht danach
fragen
wer die verantwortung für den zustand
der bundeswehr hat wir werden nicht mit
dem finger aufeinander zu zeigen
aber wir erwarten dass beim blick in die
zukunft und bei der schaffung einer
bundeswehr die wieder ihren
bündnisverpflichtungen gerecht werden
kann die opposition die bundesregierung
unterstützt
ja
ja 100 milliarden euro neben den
jährlichen haushalten das ist eine
enorme summe geld sprechen wir es offen
aus am geld allein hat es nicht
gemangelt sondern wir werden auch über
die strukturen der bundeswehr sprechen
müssen über ihren auftrag
über die möglichkeit mit den mitteln
auch tatsächlich äußere sicherheit zu
garantieren
für diese debatte sind wir offen diese
debatte werden wir führen aber die
investitionen in die bundeswehr über
friedrich merz die sollten sie nicht
führen mit der warnung von neuen
schulden das sind in wahrheit natürlich
kredite die wir aufnehmen in den
nächsten jahren aber in dieser welt lage
sind es zunächst und zumeist
investitionen in unsere freiheit
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
was sind das für mutige menschen in der
ukraine die für ihre freiheit kämpfen
die in ihrem land
unsere westlichen werte leben wollen
sie nehmen uns auch in eine
verantwortung sie nehmen uns in die
verantwortung dass auch wir hier unsere
werte ernst nehmen wir sind solidarisch
mit der ukraine
weil ein volk über seine zukunft frei
entscheiden soll aber wir sind auch
solidarisch mit der ukraine weil sie
eine inspiration für uns selbst ist ich
danke ihnen
nächste rednerin für die fraktion die
linke amira mohammed ali
[Applaus]
b gt frau präsidentin kolleginnen und
kollegen in den morgenstunden des 24
februar sind wir in einem europa
aufgewacht das nie wieder so sein wird
wie vorher wir teilen natürlich klar die
auffassung dass russland einen
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg gegen
die ukraine führt wladimir putin hat den
verhandlungstisch mutwillig verlassen
und bringt auf skrupellose art und weise
ganz europa und die welt in die konkrete
gefahr eines krieges dieser
angriffskrieg muss sofort beendet werden
soll daten müssen sofort zurückgezogen
sie wissen sie wissen dass wir als linke
häufig das verhalten der nato kritisiert
haben die sich mehrfachen nicht an
völkerrecht gehalten hat aber um es
unmissverständlich zu sagen dieser
russische angriff ist durch nichts zu
relativieren
durch nichts zu rechtfertigen kollegen
in der ukraine schweren kinder frauen
und männer angst räumt drängen sich
menschen den u-bahnhöfen familie werden
auseinandergerissen wohngebäude werden
zerstört hunderttausende sind auf der
flucht vor allem frauen und kinder die
bilder die uns täglich erreichen sind
unfassbar schockiert bei vielen menschen
in ganz europa besonders bei den älteren
die die schrecken und das leid des
zweiten weltkrieges noch erlebt haben
wächst die angst
meine meine tante helga aus heide sie
ist 95 jahre alt die rief vor ein paar
tagen an und sagte sie hat wieder angst
vor krieg auch das ist erschüttert
kolleginnen kollegen ich kann für mich
persönlich und meine partei und sicher
auch für viele hier im raum sprechen
wenn ich sage wir haben das nicht viele
möglichkeiten diesen angriffs russland
auf die ukraine diesen verbrecherischen
abgehen haben wird wie auch viele
expertin experten nicht erwartet für
meine partei die linke freue mich in
aller deutlichkeit ein dass wir die
absichten der russischen regierung
falsch eingeschätzt haben
das
das macht uns nachdenklich wir bieten
die lage heute anders und sagen klar
putin ist hier der aggressor und muss
sofort aufgehalten werden seine
großmacht fantasien die dürfen nicht
realität
wir stehen geschlossen an der seite der
polnischen bevölkerung an der seite
derer die in der ukraine um ihr leben
fürchten müssen an der seite derer die
sie auf der flucht befinden bei uns und
wir in deutschland oder in angrenzenden
ländern schutz suchen sie sind hier
bekommen wir müssen uns gemeinsam mit
den ländern der europäischen union um
diese menschen kümmern für alle menschen
jetzt wo krieg und terror aus leute
fliehen braucht es eine unbürokratische
aufnahme regelung und einen gesicherten
aufenthaltsstatus kolleginnen kollegen
bewusst bekennt sich in ihrer rede
leider vermisst wir sind auch
solidarisch mit den mutigen menschen die
zur stunde in russland putin die stirn
bieten und für den frieden demonstrieren
sie werden brachte die riskieren folgen
von den heute keiner weiß wie
schwerwiegend sie für die betroffenen
sein werden diese stimme des friedens in
russland gegen putin die müssen wir
stärken
kollegen überlegen wir stellen fest dass
wir in der bewertung dieses angriffs und
den demokratischen fraktionen in diesem
haus große einigkeit haben darum haben
wir in unserem antrag viele passagen
ihres antrags auch wörtlich übernommen
bei der frage was es jetzt allerdings zu
tun gilt sind wir in mehreren punkten
andere aufpassen denn was sich bei uns
bei aller nachdenklichkeit und
neubewertung der lage nicht geändert hat
ist unsere tiefe überzeugung dass
abrüstung und diplomatie der weg zum
frieden sind darum können wir niemals
zustimmen dass waffen in krisengebiete
geliefert werden und aufgerüstet wird er
schleust sie haben in ihrer rede gesagt
dass es ein sondervermögen geben soll
100 milliarden euro das grundgesetz soll
dafür geändert werden
und ich muss es einfach in der
deutlichkeit sagen dieses hochrüsten
diese militarisierung die können und
werden wir als linke nicht mit trauer
über zivile hilfe habe ich von ihrer
rede leider auch nichts gehört der
scheik sabah hatte ist gesagt
selbstverständlich unterstützt
unterstützen wir das was im haushalt
dieser posten zur verfügung gestellt
wird was denn sonst aber auf der einen
seite kommt ein sondervermögen auf der
anderen seite geht es um einen
haushaltsposten kolleginnen und kollegen
sei etwas entschied lang ich möchte man
sagen
die geschichte lehrt uns das wettrüsten
keine sicherheit schafft wir müssen bei
dem was wir jetzt tun nicht nur das
heute im blick haben sondern auch dass
morgen und das übermorgen und die
notwendigkeit insbesondere zur atomaren
abrüstung auf allen seiten die ist doch
heute dringlicher und deutlicher denn je
zum thema sanktionen es gibt überhaupt
kein zweifel daran dass weder putin noch
seine regierung noch die mächtige
oligarchen die hinter dem angriffskrieg
stehen irgendeine schonung verdient
haben genauso wie die russische
rüstungsindustrie
anders sieht es
anders sieht es bei der russischen
bevölkerung aus das kann man nicht
gleichsetzen denn es gibt eine tiefe
kluft zwischen den extremen reichen und
privilegierten oligarchen und der
breiten arbeitende bevölkerung da muss
man differenzieren
sanktionen die die russische führung und
die oligarchen treffen sollen die finden
wir sehr sinnvoll aber das muss ich
ihnen sagen bei den sanktionen die sie
jetzt vornehmen wird sich leider zeigen
dass sie viel weniger wirkungsvoll sein
werden als es nötig wäre
weil die reichen gegen russlands längst
mittel und wege haben sie zu umgehen
wenn sie durch die sätze lücken und
mängel in der geldwäschebekämpfung ihre
investitionen hier bei uns im land in
europa im rest der welt verstecken
können zum beispiel ein geflecht von
briefkastenfirmen weil sie ihr geld in
der schweiz in steueroasen längst in
sicherheit gebracht haben das ist ein
problem kolleginnen kollegen
aber dieses problem kann und muss man
jetzt ändern geldwäsche kann wirksam
bekämpft werden steueroasen können
ausgetrocknet werden das muss jetzt
geschehen damit die sanktionen auch
wirklich wirken können
auch die russische rüstungsindustrie
darf nicht geschont werden darum
brauchen wir sofort ein lieferstopp von
gütern insbesondere im hightech-bereich
die für rüstung verwendet werden können
die sind nach wie vor große lücken die
dringend geschlossen werden müssen denn
auch hier drohen die maßnahmen sonst
zahnlos zu sein
kolleginnen und kollegen beim thema
nation muss man sich aber auch ehrlich
machen und daher geht es ausdrücklich
nicht dass einzelinteressen von
einflussreichen lobbys berücksichtigt
werden ohne dass es irgendeine sachliche
erklärung gibt und wenn ich jetzt zb
erfahre das italienische luxus artikel
aus dem sanktionskatalog herausfallen
dann muss ich mich schon fragen welche
prioritäten gesetzt werden es geht
kolleginnen kollegen die bilder die wir
jeden tag sehen die meldungen die wir
hören die machen uns betroffen und wir
sehen aktuell noch keinen weg wie die
menschen in der ukraine schnell ein
leben in frieden frieden und freiheit
führen können ja wir brauchen sofort
einen waffenstillstand
und auch wenn es uns aktuell vielleicht
unmöglich erscheint muss unser handeln
klar von dem gedanken getragen sein dass
der tag kommt an dem man den
verhandlungstisch zurückkehren muss
eine lehre sollte sein dass wir uns
unabhängiger machen besonders von
diktatorischen regimen und dass das
völkerrecht
und die menschenrechte wichtiger sind
als wirtschaftliche interessen
danke
nächster redner für die spd fraktion dr
rolf mützenich
sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der vom
russischen präsidenten
befohlene überfall auf die ukraine ist
eine entsetzliche barbara
putin will ein folgen und eine eine
souveräne nation brechen er verantwortet
wissentlich und willentlich tod elend
und zerstörung
wir trauern mit den hinterbliebenen um
die opfer eines kriegsverbrechens dass
in diesen minuten in diesen stunden und
wahrscheinlich auch noch in den nächsten
tagen im vollen gange ist das ist putins
krieg
diese
diese zäsur meine damen und herren
bedeutet gleichwohl mehr der russische
präsident zerstört damit endgültig die
internationale ordnung die wir nach dem
kalten krieg errichten wollten vor
wenigen tagen haben sich die europäische
sicherheits ordnung aber auch die
internationale politik grundlegend
verändert
putins hochgerüstete militär und
atommacht verstößt abermals gegen das
intervention und gewalt verboten
deshalb sage ich von dieser stelle auch
an die welt heute ist eine nation auf
dem europäischen kontinent das opfer
morgen kann es auch ein land in
zentralasien treffen um die vermeintlich
russischen seelen einzusammeln wir
müssen gemeinsam gut in die stirn bieten
meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
mit vielen menschen bereit wir können
und meine damen und herren der russische
überfall ist eine rückkehr zu einer
kriegerischen großmachtpolitik es
besteht die gefahr eines flächenbrandes
wir sind der bundesregierung und unseren
verbündeten deshalb dankbar für die
klaren und eng
abgestimmten maßnahmen wir hoffen uns
die unterstützung von weiteren
regierungen außerhalb des westens
zugleich bin ich sicher meine damen und
herren dass die überwältigende mehrheit
der weltbevölkerung die aggression
verurteilt vor diesem hintergrund muss
sich vor allem die chinesische regierung
fragen wie lange sie die spannung
zwischen ihren aussenpolitischen
grundsätzen und einer mitleidlosen
interessenpolitik noch aushalten kann
präsident sie ändern sie ihren kurs
stoppen sie den krieg putins nur dann
kann china eine internationale ordnung
für den frieden in zukunft mit prägen
meine damen und herren
es war richtig dass der
un-sicherheitsrat vor zwei tagen
versucht hat die russische aggression
aufs schärfste zu verurteilen und das
rechte ukraine auf die territoriale
integrität und souveränität zu
bekräftigen
russlands wto ändert daran nichts putin
hat sein vetorecht moralisch und
politisch verwirrt meine damen und
herren
umso wichtiger ist jetzt überweisung der
resolution in die generalversammlung der
vereinten nationen
die sind fast alle länder versammelt und
das haus der staatenwelt könnte morgen
ein deutliches zeichen setzen auch dafür
meine damen und herren müssen wir
zusammen arbeiten hier im parlament aber
auch mit vielen regierungen auf der welt
putin sollte die entschlossenheit und
den zusammenhalt der freien staatenwelt
nicht unterschätzen wir haben sanktionen
verhängt die nicht nur die russische
wirtschaft und das bankensystem
sondern auch putin seine kriegstreiber
und hasardeure treffen russland wird von
den internationalen finanzmärkten
ausgeschlossen es wird die
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen der
sanktionen schmerzhaft spüren und auch
das sage ich auch wenn russland über
umfangreiche devisenreserven verfügt und
seine kriegskasse gut gefüllt ist
putin und seine handlanger sollen wissen
langfristig wird das regime die
sanktionen spüren und das ist die klare
botschaft die heute auch hier aus berlin
in richtung moskau ausgesendet wird
meine damen und herren
dazu müssen wir die kommenden tage noch
größeren unterstützerkreis schaffen das
heißt dann aber auch und auch das sage
ich sehr deutlich unser land ist bereit
die finanziellen und wirtschaftlichen
konsequenzen zu tragen
darüber darf sich niemand heute hinweg
täuschen lassen sie mich es deutlich
sagen ja der krieg in der ukraine
bedeutet das scheitern aller bisherigen
diplomatischen bemühungen das ist
schmerzhaft und peter
und das sage ich auch gerade für
jemanden der wie ich bis zum schluss
alle diplomatischen mittel nutzen wollte
und genutzt sehen wollte deshalb danke
ich bundeskanzler olaf scholz und
stellvertretend für die gesamte
bundesregierung annalena baerbock für
die unermüdliche arbeit ebenso wie den
französischen und dem amerikanischen
präsidenten dem britischen premier und
allen unseren freunden und partner die
nichts unversucht gelassen haben putin
von diesem schritt abzuhalten vielen
dank
hervorheben möchte ich auch die
weitgehende einigkeit in diesem haus von
der diplomatie über waffenlieferungen
bis hin zum bankensystem am ende unserer
debatte werden wir zusammen mit der
union eine gemeinsame
resolution verabschieden dass sie sein
starkes zeichen des zusammenhalts in
einer existenziellen krise dafür möchte
ich mich bei ihnen im märz ganz herzlich
bedanken
mit der invasion wurden die hoffnungen
und die arbeit für eine friedlichere
welt auf der zehnte wahrscheinlich
zurückgeworfen
junge und nachfolgende generationen
werden uns dafür
verurteilen dass wir älteren ist nicht
vermocht haben eine bessere welt zu
schaffen sei es beim klima der armut
oder beim militär
und rüstung und ich kann für viele hier
in diesem haus versprechen solange wir
können müssen wir diese schuld abtragen
meine damen und herren
die um sich greifende missachtung
internationaler normen die einseitige
kündigung von abrüstungsverträgen und
das eigenmächtige verstörende auftreten
mancher staatschef in den letzten jahren
haben die welt nicht sicherer gemacht
nichts rechtfertigt putins krieg wir
müssen ihm grenzen setzen und neue
russische aggression eindämmen dafür
braucht es beides eine glaubhafte
verteidigung aber eben auch gemeinsam
eine kluge außenpolitik meine damen und
herren und deswegen ja wir müssen die
bundeswehr in die lage versetzen diese
aufgabe gerecht zu werden unsere
streitkräfte müssen die ausrüstung
bekommen die sie brauchen deswegen haben
wir in den vergangenen
jahren den verteidigungshaushalt erhöht
und wir werden das auch in zukunft
verantwortungsvoll tun meine damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
gleichzeitig und auch das
noch das sage ich in voller kenntnis
auch der großen herausforderung
gleichzeitig müssen wir das geld besser
und effizienter einsetzen kollege
lindner hat darauf hingewiesen auch
innerhalb der europäischen union und der
nato
allein wir europäer geben jährlich über
200 milliarden euro für verteidigung aus
und deswegen sind wir überzeugt eine
effiziente verteidigungspolitik meine
damen und herren darf sich nicht in
ansätzen erschöpfen
auch wenn wir uns heute auch die
wehrhaftigkeit konzentrieren müssen
dürfen wir die anderen elemente einer
gerechten und demokratischen
sicherheitspolitik nicht vernachlässigen
deshalb war es ein gutes zeichen dass
wir noch am tag des russischen angriffs
zusätzlich fünf millionen euro für den
ukraine hilfsfonds der vereinten
nationen bereit gestellt haben dies ist
eine botschaft an die kriegsflüchtlinge
die binnenflüchtlinge in der ukraine
aber auch die versuchen nach europa zu
kommen wir stehen ihnen in schwere not
zur seite auch durch die aufnahme in die
länder der europäischen union meine
damen und herren
unser respekt und unsere anerkennung
am schluss seiner rede den mutigen
russischen staatsbürger die öffentlich
oder im sinn des zivilen ungehorsams die
barbarei ihres präsidenten verurteilt
sie zeigen damit der welt dass es ein
anderes russland gibt in russland das
teil der völkergemeinschaft sein möchte
und in frieden mit seinen nachbarn leben
vielen dank für die aufmerken
nächster redner für die cdu csu fraktion
alexander dobrindt
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
der krieg ist im 21 jahrhundert in die
mitte europas zurückgekehrt
das unmögliche des wirklichkeit geworden
und ich weiß nicht was überwiegt wenn
man die bilder sieht wie leben von
jungen menschen in uniformen von frauen
und kindern in der zivilbevölkerung
zerstört wird ist es trauer oder ist es
die wut die einen erfasst aber eines
überwiegt sicher größer als der hass
putins auf die ukraine ist unsere
solidarität mit den menschen und dem
volk der ukraine meine damen und herren
der bundeskanzler
sie haben in ihrer regierungserklärung
aus unserer sicht
richtig dargelegt dass der ausschluss
russlands aus dem swift finanzsystem
jetzt notwendig ist sie haben richtig
dargelegt dass die
verteidigungsfähigkeit der ukraine zu
unterstützen ist und wir waffen zu
liefern haben sie haben uns bei diesen
maßnahmen an ihrer seite sowohl was das
finanzsystem anbelangt als auch was die
lieferung von
verteidigungswaffen an die ukraine
betrifft wir haben seit mehreren tagen
festgestellt dass unsere partner in
europa dieses vorgehen auch von
deutschland eingefordert haben und wir
wollen im gleichklang mit unseren
europäischen und amerikanischen
partnern handeln und um dies auch
deutlich zu sagen es darf auch bei
weiteren notwendigen maßnahmen keinen
sonderweg deutschlands auf der bremse
geben dann haben sie uns weiterhin an
ihrer seite herr bundeskanzler
um auch das klarzustellen und für alle
unmissverständlich weil es natürlich
große debatten auch in der
öffentlichkeit darüber gibt wenn wir
waffen liefern in kriegsgebiete ja es
geht bei diesen lieferungen von waffen
uns nicht darum krieg zu führen es geht
darum verhandlungen wieder zu
ermöglichen und es zu schaffen dass
diejenigen die angegriffen sich auch
wehren können meine damen und herren
putin hat den frieden in europa zerstört
und wir müssen sehen dass unsere idee
frieden durch handel durch
wirtschaftliche verflechtung nicht
funktioniert wir waren uns sicher dass
der gemeinsame austausch von waren dass
der handel automatisch zu einem
friedlichen miteinander führt und es ist
auch nicht und es war auch nicht falsch
daran zu glauben aber es hat schlichtweg
nicht ausgereicht frieden zu sichern
braucht mehr als wirtschaftlicher stärke
frieden zu sichern braucht auch starke
sicherheitsgarantien und es braucht eine
starke verteidigungsfähigkeit meine
damen und herren
und ich hoffe dass wir in diesem
parlament einer meinung sind putin hat
nicht nur den frieden europas zerstört
putin hat auch die friedensdividende
zerstört politisch wirtschaftlich
gesellschaftlich haben wir in der
vergangenheit von dieser
friedensdividende
profitiert aber liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen setzte die es in diesem
parlament gegeben hat die geheißen haben
immer mehr ausrüstungen können nicht die
antwort sein diese sätze passen nicht
mehr in die zeit die antwort muss
zwingend heissen mehr ausrüstung mehr
militärtechnik und vor allem mehr
wertschätzung gegenüber unseren
soldatinnen und soldaten und der
bundeswehr liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und ja das hat sich abgezeichnet dass
die wachsenden aufgaben der bundeswehr
die auf sie zukamen und die mittel die
dafür bereit gestellt worden sind nicht
zusammenpassen ja es hat sich
abgezeichnet in der tat und der 24
februar der muss jedem klar sein das ist
die zäsur des landes und
bündnisverteidigung
wieder allerhöchste priorität haben muss
wie viele länder in europa verlassen
sich auf deutschland wenn es um die
bündnis garantien geht meine damen und
herren und wie viele in deutschland auch
in der politik glaubten dass die
sicherheitsgarantien im bündnis
alleinige aufgabe der vereinigten
staaten von amerika sind ich sage ihnen
wenn wir nicht wenn wir nicht die
sicherheit in europa garantieren wollen
warum sollten es dann die vereinigten
staaten von amerika tun
und deswegen will ich an dieser stelle
schon auch sagen
wenn man zuhört was hier von der linken
seite auch kommt das alles lässt sich in
frage stellt was wir gerade hier
diskutieren über die
verteidigungsfähigkeit
und wer fähigkeit europas der nato und
der bundesrepublik deutschland
ich glaube wir sollten das gemeinsame
bekenntnis abgeben wir brauchen für
unsere
verteidigungsfähigkeit auch die nukleare
teilhabe und es ist unverantwortlich
diese nukleare teilhabe in frage zu
stellen meine damen und herren
in den letzten tagen und wochen war
immer wieder zu hören und auch zu lesen
putin sei stark und der westen sei
schwach all denjenigen die so etwas
gesagt oder geschrieben haben ich kann
ihnen nur sagen unsere stärke ist nicht
einfach nur militärisch unsere stärke
ist vor allem auch demokratisch meine
damen und herren wenn der westen schwach
wäre dann würde putin ihn nicht fürchten
und würde nicht versuchen dass länder
wie die ukraine sich ihm anschließen
wollen wir sind deswegen stark weil wir
für demokratie für wohlstand und für
freiheit steht das sind die werte die
putin seinem eigenen volk vorenthält und
deswegen für vier jahre und meine damen
und herren
europäische union und nato sichern
freiheit und wohlstand ihrer mitglieder
und deswegen wollen gerade auch die
länder aus dem ehemaligen ostblock sich
uns anschließen und sie wollen es auch
genau deswegen tun weil sie den
unterschied kennen zwischen einer
partnerschaft in der eu und der nato und
einer partnerschaft mit putin wir wollen
dass unsere freunde und partner auf
eigenen beinen in freiheit stehen können
putin will dass sie sich in den staub
werfen meine damen und herren wir
haben vor 70 jahren im deutschen
bundestag 1952 im februar
eine debatte über die wiederbewaffnung
der bundesrepublik deutschland geführt
es ging damals um den beitritt zur
europäischen
verteidigungsgemeinschaft
friedenspolitik heißt verzicht darauf
politische ziele mit gewalt durchsetzen
zu wollen er damals franz josef strauß
gesagt und weiter erklärt
friedenspolitik heißt aber auch einen
angreifer klar zu machen dass sein
angriff auf den gesamt widerstand europa
stoßen wird dieser satz ist heute so
richtig wie damals wir können den
angriff auf die ukraine nicht mehr
verhindern aber wir können dafür sorgen
dass das nicht so weitergeht krieg und
gewalt dürfen schlichtweg nicht das
letzte wort in der geschichte sein marie
damen und herren gott schütze die
ukraine
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die bundesregierung
der bundesminister dr robert habeck
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren erlauben sie auch mir noch ein
paar
einordnen bemerkung zur situation zum
handeln der bundesregierung und zu
diesen tagen wochenstunden und zu dieser
plenardebatte die sicherlich in zehn
jahren als historisch beurteilt werden
wird
ukraine heißt grenzland ein land am rand
von europa so sagt es der name einen run
ein land am rand von russland und immer
wieder wurde seine territoriale
integrität
zerstört erobert nicht geachtet ein land
das so eine wechselvolle geschichte als
rand land als grenzland wie ist der name
ja selber sagt erlebt hat hat natürlich
manchmal probleme seine eigene
staatlichkeit zu entwickeln aber der
wille der menschen in der ukraine seit
30 jahren für die freiheiten für die
demokratie einzutreten ist
unerschütterlich geblieben und wir reden
hier nicht nur alleine über die
grenzfragen wir reden darüber ob der
wille zur freiheit und demokratie der
selbstbestimmung wille dieses landes
erhalten und verteidigt wird das
bedeutet die auseinandersetzung die wir
eigentlich gerade diskutieren und das
rechtfertigt auch die unbestreitbare
solidarität dieses hauses und dieser
bundesregierung mit der ukraine
das ist die freiheit
es ist die freiheit die putin züchtet
und er hat es selbst gesagt hat einer
neben bedeutung in einem gespräch mit
dem französischen präsidenten mag als
ein russisches kinder lee zitiert hat
das mädchen vorgelesen vorgesungen wird
denn die haarige manchmal ziehen wenn
sie gekämpft werden dass aber ein
synonym fährverkehr vergewaltigung ist
die ukraine soll sich nicht so anstellen
sie würde jetzt halt vergewaltigt werden
so hat der präsident gesprochen er weiß
was er tut und wer bei einer
militärischen vergewaltigung zuschaut
macht sich schuldig haben deswegen
müssen wir handeln und müssen wir unsere
position so stark machen dass wir der
ukraine helfen in dieser stunde der
militärischen vergewaltigungs not
es sind sicherlich rückblickend fehler
gemacht worden und auch das gilt es
aufzuarbeiten und auch das tun wir
gerade wenn man in der ukraine war dann
hat man die frustration an allen ecken
gespürt dass die haltung des westens
offenbar unklar die tür ist offen aber
ihr dürft nicht durch wir halten an
unseren prinzipien fest aber bezahlen
sollen andere den preis wir wollen guten
der partnerschaft und handel durch
wandel aber wir sind nicht achtsam genug
um zu sehen in welcher abhängigkeit wir
geraten
beispielsweise durch die hohe
energiepolitische abhängigkeit
deutschlands von russischem öl kohle
oder gas im trocken man hatte also genug
waren stimmen und wir waren politisch
nicht wachsam und nicht klar genug
darauf zu antworten
umgekehrt ist die deutsche geschichte
eine schwere hypothek
ukraine russland polen bilder russ wir
wissen ja gar nicht von welchem land für
uns zuerst entschuldigen sollen aufgrund
all der massaker der angriffsziele und
des rückens von deutschen in diesen
ländern insofern achte ich und ich achte
ist hoch eine position des unbedingten
pazifismus die sich sicherlich auch aus
dieser geschichte ableitet und sagt wir
können nicht weiter nächste schuld auf
uns lagen ich achte aber ich halte es
für falsch denn schuldig werden wir
trotzdem wir kommen mit sauberen händen
dann aus der sache nicht raus deswegen
ist die korrektur die die
bundesregierung gemacht hat also die
bereitschaft waffen zu liefern richtig
sie ist richtig weil nur eine position
die sagen würde nur wenn jemand waffen
liefert ist alles richtig also lassen
wir die ukraine alleine hoffen wir
darauf dass sie schnell überrannt wird
die logisch konsequente position ist die
können wir aber aus den genannten grund
nicht einnehmen deswegen so schwer es
ist es ist die richtige positionierung
und die richtige entscheidung aber
sie ist richtig aber
ob sie gut ist das weiß heute keiner und
ich weiß es auch nicht und ich habe mich
ja immer sehr offen dafür gezeigt diesen
schritt zu gehen
dann wird weiß schon wie sich der krieg
entwickelt und wer weiß ob aus dieser
entscheidung heraus nicht weitere
entscheidungen getroffen werden und hier
irgendwann lauter waffen liefern für
einen dauerhaften lang krieg in europa
auch das ist möglich wir müssen deswegen
uns leiten lassen von der
grundprinzipien frage warum wir uns auch
solche schweren auch uns an die grenze
führenden entscheidungen zumuten und
diese antwort kann nur in der
solidarität mit der freiheit und der
demokratie der völker und der menschen
stehen die für diese kämpfen das kann
aber konsequenzen haben und die
bundesregierung wird auch ich in meinem
amt alles dafür tun alles dafür tun die
konsequenzen auf deutschland den schaden
vom deutschen volk fernzuhalten wir
werden also für die bereiche der
wirtschaft die möglicherweise von
sanktionen betroffen sind ähnliche
schutzmaßnahmen machen wie wir es in der
korona kann debi getan haben wir werden
die reserven für kohle öl und gas
hochhalten und sind schon längst dabei
wir werden aber auch dem ausstieg aus
der verbrennung von fossilen energien
deutlich beschleunigen müssen und nicht
mehr über jahrzehnte reden an dieser
stelle wir werden also einen
ausstiegsplan aus dem fossilen energien
vorlegen und mit voller kraft umsetzen
wir werden das gesetz die speicher voll
zu halten zeitnah vorlegen und ich werde
auf die fraktion zu gehen und sie bitten
dieses gesetz einzubringen damit wir
möglichst wenig zeit verlieren wir
werden einen hochlauf von wasserstoff
und erneuerbaren energien brauchen es
ist gut in die militärische sicherheit
zu investieren aber lassen sie mich an
dieser stelle klar sein die
energieversorgung und die souveränität
der energieversorgung ist ebenfalls eine
frage von nationaler sicherheit geworden
auch daran werden wir investieren müssen
der krieg ist in russland nicht populär
es gibt demonstrationen dagegen in 50
städten über tausend menschen sind am
ersten tag alleine verhaftet worden man
riecht sie förmlich die angst der
potentaten die angst vor putin vor
seinem eigenen volk und wenn wir uns
darüber klar machen worüber wir
entscheiden wann sehen wir ist hier was
den systemischen unterschied macht und
dass diesem tag was diese tage maskiert
markiert es ist die angst der potentaten
vor ihren eigenen menschen der den
unterschied macht es ist die angst der
autoritären vor ihrer eigenen
bevölkerung die den unterschied macht
hier die angst der machthaber dort der
mut zur freiheit die hoffnung auf
selbstbestimmung der mut auf die straße
zu gehen das macht den unterschied aus
das ist die provokation der freiheit die
für ihn und die seinen nicht aushalten
insofern ist es eine systemfrage an der
wir heute stehen denken wir nicht nur
bis zur grenze denken wir darüber hinaus
seien wir in zukunft wachsam und nicht
arglos wenn wachsamkeit der preis der
freiheit ist dann wollen wir nicht
wieder schlafmützig sein setzen wir also
auf die freiheit vertrauen wir auf die
menschen und die menschlichkeit vielen
dank
herr minister
doch für harnik
nächster redner ist der kollege tino
europa hat die fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
landsleute
lassen sie mich zu beginn eine
feststellung machen und allen vorrednern
auch dahingehend recht geben russland
hat die ukraine angegriffen und wir
haben wieder krieg in europa das
bestürzt mich als politiker bürger
deutschlands
und als familienvater zutiefst fest
steht dass die konflikt ursachen
mindestens acht jahre zurückliegen und
komplex sind es darf in diesen tagen
aber nicht unser ziel sein den einen
schuldigen auszumachen
wir müssen die diskussion auch da hin
zur lösung zu einer gemeinsamen zukunft
leiten im mittelpunkt im mittelpunkt
sollten jetzt genauso deutschland und
seine bürger stehen wie auch die rolle
der europäischen staaten und völker und
meine damen und herren russland ist
ebenso teil dessen wie die ukraine und
herr linder es gibt immer hoffnung auch
hoffnung in einen krieg und russland ist
ebensowenig la die mir putin wie
deutschland frank walter steinmeier ist
so einfach ist das nicht
und wir dürfen gerade in diesen tagen
russlands beitrag für deutschland und
europa eben nicht vergessen auch dadurch
wurde vor 32 jahren die deutsche einheit
ermöglicht untermauert durch den abzug
russischer truppen im jahr 1994 dem
müssen wir respekt zollen und das sage
ich ganz bewusst auch aus ostdeutscher
wir danken russland bis heute dafür
liebe kollegen
schuldzuweisungen und zuschreibungen
erzeugen keine lösung sondern heizen den
konflikt immer weiter an vielmehr stimme
ich allen rednern zu die sich für
deeskalation entschärfung in worten und
taten stark machen und ich rufe selbst
zur mäßigung auf wir alle wollen frieden
in deutschland und europa und deshalb
werde die bundesregierung
versammeln sie bitte alle partner am
verhandlungstisch verlassen sie den denk
korridor des ost west konfliktes und
skizzieren sie eine gemeinsame zukunft
des europäischen kontinents dafür müssen
wir im dialog bleiben
mögliche
mögliche lösung setzen zugeständnisse
auf beiden seiten voraus
und herr scholz sie haben heute leider
den kalten krieg reaktiviert mit ihrer
rede das muss ich so deutlich sagen
leider sehe ich im moment leider sehe
ich ihnen einen moment und das habe ich
in den vorräten alles schon gehört ein
überbietungswettbewerb am schnellsten
und am effektivsten die brücken nach
osten abzubrechen zb die geldströme oder
nord stream wie herr bundeskanzler stolz
das möchte oder verkehrswege sodass
aeroflot nicht mehr landen darf und da
muss man würde die frage stellen wem
nutzt das wem nutzt das und welche
folgen er kaufen wir uns damit und herr
nazi haben von interessen gesprochen
welche interessen sie verfolgen das
wissen wir alle deutsche interessen sind
es definitiv nicht
und wir müssen fragen welche sozialen
folgen hat ihre politik für die
deutschen bürger diese müssen schon
jetzt überall mit steigenden preisen
leben stichworte benzinpreise heizkosten
steigende inflation denken sie bitte
auch daran welche signale sie den
nachfolgenden generationen geben wollen
sie allen ernstes die bundesregierung
seien die wieder soldaten in einen krieg
gegen russland schickt das nehmen wir
ebenso ab wie die lieferung von waffen
in kriegsgebiete
werte kollegen wir als deutschland in
der mitte europas sind leidgeprüft und
gerade wir könnten mit unseren
erfahrungen eigenständig und
selbstbewusst für ein stabiles sicheres
europa aufdrehen und neutral in diesem
konflikt vermitteln und deshalb rufe ich
der bundesregierung zu planen sie nicht
wie wir beziehungen verschlechtern
sondern wie wir von wladiwostok bis
lissabon wohlstand sicherheit und eine
friedliche koexistenz aller nationen
garantieren könnten wir brauchen
stabilität
es darf auf keinen fall darin münden
dass sie schon jetzt die nächste
migrationswelle planen wer wie wir die
ukraine als eigenständigen staat
betrachtet muss sich auch für diesen
einsätzen und nicht dessen die
stabilisierung begünstigen meine damen
und herren bei allem streit für das gute
entpuppt sich eine scheinbar klare
position für freiheit und demokratie
auch mal als sackgasse der chef der
münchner philharmoniker bei jähriger gf
soll sich von russischer politik
distanzieren weil der russe ist ich weiß
nicht ob das für sie auch ein
repräsentant ist er soll sich bis montag
entscheiden ansonsten wird den
arbeitsplatz gekündigt ist es ein
einzelfall oder werden bald alle
russischen bürger in deutschland in
sippenhaft genommen das ist wirklich
unfassbar
und diese forderung diese forderung
stammt vom sozialdemokratischen
oberbürgermeister münchens dieter reiter
ideologie getriebene cancelled für
freiheit und demokratie und wie es dazu
die position der bundesregierung vor
staatsministerin rot wählen glaubt man
denn damit zu treffen etwa putin das ist
reine machtsymbole und unangemessen die
zeiten in denen auge um auge zahn um
zahn galt sind vorbei meine damen und
herren ebenso wichtig wie die
deutsch-französische muss die deutsch
russische freundschaft sein
gegenseitiger achtung und respekt sind
die grundlage für eine gemeinsame
zukunft stabile verhältnisse auf einen
europäischen kontinent sind dabei in
unserem interesse ein neues wettrüsten
lehnen wir ab und deswegen diese 100
milliarden er stolz das ist wirklich als
fraktionsvorsitzender und bundessprecher
der alternative deutschland werde ich
mich persönlich weiterhin für den dialog
mit allen verhandlungspartnern und für
den frieden einsetzen vielen dank
naja
die kollegen kollegen nächster redner
ist der kollege christian dürr fdp
platzieren
verehrter herr präsident lieber
kollegen kollegen ich wollte eigentlich
nicht darauf eingehen aber
nicht dass wir worte der anteilnahme für
das ukrainische volk von der afg
erwartet hätten allerdings die realität
in europa so zu verzehren wie sie es
gerade getan haben ist niederträchtig
herr vorteil
und ich will ihn da fragen
die bundesrepublik deutschland ist eine
wehrhafte demokratie nach außen das
beweist die mehrheit des deutschen
bundestages gerade aber sie ist es auch
nach innen gegen die feinde der
demokratie um das in aller klarheit
sagen kolleginnen kollegen
wladimir putin führt einen angriffskrieg
mitten in europa die ukraine hat putins
krieg nicht provoziert es gab in keinem
moment eine glaubwürdige bedrohung für
russland durch die ukraine wladimir
putins begründung für diesen krieg sind
auch desinformation auf propaganda und
lügen gebaut ist grenzt an zynismus wenn
der russische präsident behauptet ziel
seines angriffs sei eine
entnazifizierung der ukraine es ist
gelogen wenn er behauptet im don was für
über die ukraine eine genozid oder die
ukraine wolle nuklearwaffen um moskau zu
bedrohen meine damen und herren war ist
wladimir putin ist der agresso in diesem
konflikt und das muss deutlich
ausgesprochen werden
der russische präsident bricht mit
seiner entscheidung zum angriff auf die
ukraine auch schwerste das völkerrecht
er bricht alle grundlegenden regeln der
internationalen ordnung die kst
schlussakte von 1975 die charta von
paris von 1990 die butter das budapester
momenten memorandum von 1994 die nato
russland grund akte von 1997 der 2008
verlängerte freundschaftsvertrag der
ukraine mit russland und die charta der
vereinten nationen meine damen und
herren wer das bricht der ist ein
verbrecher liebe kollegen kollegen
und deshalb ist es richtig dass der
deutsche bundestag diesen angriffskrieg
der russischen des russischen
präsidenten auf das schärfste verurteilt
wir dürfen nicht schweigen wenn ein
souveränes mitglied der
staatengemeinschaft angegriffen wird
deshalb ist es richtig dass die
internationale gemeinschaft harte
konsequenzen zieht und umfassend
sanktionen verhängt gezielte sanktionen
insbesondere auch gegen die person
wladimir putin und sein umfeld um die
oligarchen und seine unterstützer zu
treffen und ich will dass in richtung
des bundeskanzlers und des
bundesfinanzministers sagen es war in
der gestrigen nacht eine richtige
entscheidung das scharfe schwert zu
ziehen und russlands banken von swift
abzukoppeln sie haben die ausdrückliche
unterstützung des deutschen bundestages
herr finanzminister der bundeskanzler in
dieser frage
und das gleiche gilt für die
waffenlieferung die in der gestrigen
nacht entschieden worden sind jedes
freie volk hat wenn es angegriffen wird
wird das recht sich zu verteidigen
unsere solidarität ist mit russland an
mit der ukraine
unsere solidarität ist mit der ukraine
an dieser stelle eben auch über diesen
weg da kämpfen menschen gerade um ihr
leben und überleben soldaten verteidigen
irland das ist es deswegen ist es
richtig dass wir die ukraine mit
waffenlieferung an dieser stelle
unterstützen zur verteidigung des
eigenen landes und von menschenleben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und ich will
an dieser stelle auch auf einen punkt
eingehen ich will auf ihre räder
eingehen herr merz ich fand das auch in
den letzten tagen auch miteinander
gesprochen ausdrücklich gut und
hilfreich dass die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
gesagt hat sie unterstützt die
bundesregierung bei dem was jetzt vor
uns liegt ein schwerer weg auch für
unser land und diese kooperation diese
einmütigkeit dafür danke ich ihnen sie
haben in ihrer rede gerade gesagt wir
stehen vor einem scherbenhaufen der
sicherheitspolitik ich teile diese
entscheidung und es geht christian
lindner hat es vorhin gesagt nicht um
schuldzuweisung dabei sondern es geht um
gemeinsame verantwortung und deswegen
herr merz fordere ich sie auf tragen sie
diese gemeinsame verantwortung der
bundeskanzler und der
bundesfinanzminister habe neben vorhaben
skizziert wie wir die
verteidigungsfähigkeit unseres landes im
nato-bündnis stärken ich fordere ihre
fraktion auch dem beizutreten und das
auch mehrheitlich zu unterstützen sollte
eine zweidrittel mehrheit im deutschen
bundestag für eine grundgesetzänderung
nötig seien liebe kollegen kollegen hier
war bundeskanzler per finanzminister
liebes kabinett ich habe das starke
gefühl sie haben für das was sie hier
vorgetragen haben die große mehrheit des
deutschen bundestages hinter sich und
das ist ein ganz wichtiges signal vor
dem hintergrund dieses konflikts in die
welt liebe kollegen leben
und ich will an der stelle sagen
kann ist dass alle bewegt
ein europa in dem nicht
dem streit nicht mit krieg sondern
friedlich gelöst wird ist ein europa so
wie wir es uns vorstellen und es ist ein
europa wie deutschland dazu beigetragen
hat es nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
aufzubauen viele haben gesagt putins
angriff ist ein angriff auf ganz europa
doch es ist in wahrheit vielmehr ein
angriff auf die gesamte menschheit auf
das grundrecht jeder person in frieden
und freiheit zu leben wir stehen an der
schwelle eines neuen jahrhunderts in dem
dieser hart erkämpften rechte weltweit
bedroht werden deswegen ist der krieg in
der ukraine ein krieg für die rechte
aller menschen und überall hinter der
ukraine steht nicht nur die europäische
union und europa sondern die ganze
demokratische welt sowie all diejenigen
die woanders gegen autokratische staaten
für freiheit kämpfen meine damen und
herren es geht um die freiheit in der
welt an dieser stelle und deswegen steht
die bundesrepublik deutschland als
liberale demokratin an der seite des
ukrainischen volkes und herr botschafter
ich will sie an der stelle direkt
ansprechen der deutsche bundestag die
menschen in deutschland leiden derzeit
mit ihrem volk wir stehen solidarisch an
der seite der demokratischen
institutionen und dem ukrainischen volk
auch das ist eine botschaft des der
sondersitzung des deutschen bundestages
an dem heutigen tage herr botschafter
und zum schluss liebe kollegen kollegen
will ich auch ein wort richten an das
russische volk ich weiß dass viele
gerade überlegen auf die straße zu gehen
viele menschen russland sind bereits
verhaftet worden weil sie sich gegen das
autokratische regime von wladimir putin
stellen wir wollen den menschen an
dieser stelle in russland aussagen wir
haben höchsten respekt für diejenigen
die sich gegen wladimir putin auflehnen
die in den letzten tagen laut gegen den
krieg in die in der ukraine gesprochen
haben und in russland auf die straßen
gehen auch diese menschen haben unsere
ausdrückliche solidarität liebe kollegen
kollegen
wir als deutsche wie ein europäer wir
dürfen uns nicht kleinreden europa ist
ein sehnsuchtsort unser demokratisches
system ist ein symbol der hoffnung für
viele und gemeinsam liebe kollegen
kollegen gemeinsam sind wir stärker als
die kraft der autarkie und der
kriegstreiberei ich danke ihnen
vielen dank herr kollege hören
als nächste rednerin erhält das wort die
die kollegin saskia esken spd-fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident für die kolleginnen und
kollegen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren
der russische machthaber wladimir putin
hat mit abscheulicher arroganz das
völkerrecht gebrochen und die ukraine
überfall
putin hat den krieg und das
blutvergießen in europa wieder ins hier
und jetzt geholt in einem jetzt an dem
ganz europa gemeinsam gearbeitet hat aus
verantwortung vor krieg und leid in
unserer geschichte damit es uns damit es
unseren kindern und enkeln heute und
morgen ein leben in frieden ermöglicht
doch nun haben wir krieg in europa
und dieser krieg ist putins krieg putin
führt diesen krieg gegen die ukraine
doch vor allem führt er diesen krieg
gegen das was er als diktator am meisten
fürchtet demokratie und freiheit
und so stehen die farben der ukraine die
farben europas heute auch für demokratie
und freiheit und die sind stärker als
das autoritäre welt mit des russischen
diktators
in russland in georgien in ganz europa
gehen menschen auf die strassen gegen
diesen krieg und für den frieden putin
führt krieg auch gegen die menschen im
eigenen land tausende wurden
festgenommen die proteste durch die
russische staatsgewalt brutal
niedergeschlagen die
friedensdemonstrationen wie sie gerade
heute in berlin und anderswo in
deutschland europa stattfinden geben
auch denjenigen eine stimme die nicht
sprechen können ohne ihr leben zu
gefährden
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
nicht erst seit putins überfall sind
menschen in unserer mitte in unserer
mitte in großer sorge um ihre mütter und
väter ihre brüder und schwestern
freundinnen freunde in der ukraine und
in russland
sie halten kontakt sie leisten beistand
sie versorgen die menschen mit
verlässlichen informationen doch seit
dem 24 februar sind die antworten auf
ihre anrufe und nachrichten spärlich
geworden denn die menschen sind auf der
flucht sie versteckten sich sie müssen
leise sein weil sie angst haben entdeckt
zu werden sie schreiben wenn sie können
kurznachrichten und hektisch
geschriebene hilfe rufen das sind
zeugnisse voller sorge und angst sorge
und angst auch um die soldatinnen und
soldaten die hier leben und viel land
kämpfen und doch scheint auch immer
wieder hoffnung durch hoffnung darauf
dass ukrainerinnen und ukrainer in ihrer
heimat bald wieder in frieden und
freiheit leben können
putin führt in der ukraine einen krieg
gegen die menschen und er führt einen
krieg gegen die menschlichkeit
der überfall auf die ukraine ist
insofern eine zäsur in erbricht mit den
grundprinzipien der internationalen
gemeinschaft es ist unsere vordringliche
aufgabe diesen blutigen krieg so schnell
wie möglich zu beenden
deshalb werden die sanktionen der
internationalen gemeinschaft nochmals
geschärft und dabei kommt es
entscheidend darauf an unkalkulierbare
auswirkungen auf die bevölkerung
abzuwenden oder sie wo nötig auch
auszugleichen
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
die maxime deutscher außenpolitik keine
waffen in krisengebiete zu liefern ist
tief in unserer historischen
verantwortung verwurzelt
dass die bundesrepublik deutschland
jetzt waffen an die ukraine zur
selbstverteidigung liefert ist in dieser
situation eine tragische notwendigkeit
und moralisch geboten
diese entscheidung schulden wir der
solidarität mit der ukrainischen
bevölkerung und wir schulden sie unseren
geteilten europäischen werten von
demokratie und freiheit
und bundeskanzler scholz hat deshalb
meinen tiefen respekt und meine
anerkennung diese schwierige
entscheidung von großer tragweite
verantwortungsvoll getroffen zu haben
mit unserer bundeswehr werden dir als
mitglied von nato und europäischer union
für die sicherheit in europa unseren
beitrag leisten darauf ist verlass heute
und in der zukunft unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten haben unseren tiefen
respekt um ihre aufgabe erfüllen zu
können müssen sie bestmöglich
ausgestattet sein dafür auch dafür steht
diese bundesregierung
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
die menschen in europa sind in großer
solidarität an der seite der ukraine und
sichern ihre hilfe zu für viele
schutzsuchende ist polen der erste
sichere hafen und erhält dafür im rahmen
der eu auch alle notwendige
unterstützung
auch viele deutsche städte können und
wollen sichere häfen seien denen
menschen die sich hier solidarisch
zeigen die anpacken und helfen wollen
gilt mein großer dank
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
ich bin der festen überzeugung dass
demokratie und freiheit immer obsiegen
werden dafür werden menschen immer und
zu jeder zeit bereit sein zu kämpfen
unsere gedanken sind in dieser schweren
zeit bei unseren freundinnen und
freunden in der ukraine die in diesen
tagen freiheit und demokratie
verteidigen vielen dank
[Applaus]
die studie ist die kollegin patricia
lips cdu csu fraktion
herr präsident kolleginnen und kollegen
gehörten es in vielen reden es ist krieg
nicht irgendwo weit weg sondern mitten
in europa
und es zeigt sich wie schön es ist wie
einfach es ist ein hohelied auf europa
zu singen sich zu freuen zu bekennen die
europäische union als das größte
friedensprojekt in der nachkriegszeit
die bedeutung jetzt zu erkennen aber
kolleginnen und kollegen es gilt auch
die bewährungsprobe ist jetzt und ich
danke dass wir hier in dieser form
zusammen stehen hier im haus jetzt in
deutschland und auch innerhalb der
europäischen union ein nachbar wird
angegriffen es wird bewusst leid und
zerstörung in kauf genommen heute ist es
die ukraine aber sollte der plan
gelingen so möchten wir uns doch nicht
aus marl dieses vorgehen wo es als
präzedenzfall ebenfalls in die tat
umgesetzt würde ob durch putin an
weiteren grenzen seines landes oder
einem anderen aggressor anderswo auf der
welt machen wir uns bewusst welche
gedanken und sorgen in diesen tagen vor
allem auch die menschen in vilnius in
prag und warschau beschäftigen
kriegsangst geht um und welche
erwartungen hoffnungen sie mit uns
verbinden die letzten tage und stunden
haben es gezeigt man schaut auf uns
deshalb lassen sie uns diese hoffnungen
nicht enttäuschen nicht weiter
enttäuschend ist man leider versucht zu
sagen es geht um solidarität mit den
menschen in der ukraine
überall finden kundgebungen und
mahnwachen mit tausenden von menschen
statt an vielen stellen erstrahlen die
nationalfahnen der ukraine unsere
gedanken sind bei den menschen in diesem
land aber kolleginnen und kollegen
solidarität braucht auch glaubwürdigkeit
wir sehen
die sich von ihren familien
verabschieden männer die unzureichende
bewaffnet gegen panzer kämpfen ein
präsident der zum ausdruck bringt ich
bin da ich bleibe bei euch bilder die
gerade um die welt gehen freiheit ist
nicht selbstverständlich wir haben es
bereits heute mehrfach gehört sie hat
ihren preis für die menschen in der
ukraine wird dieser preis aktuell mit
der angst um ihr eigenes leben bezahlt
vergessen wir nicht sie kämpfen diesen
kampf auch für uns der angriff auf
dieses land ist ein angriff auf unser
aller wertesystem und
leben wir heute über sanktionen reden
auch solche die auswirkungen auf uns
selbst haben dann muss uns die
verteidigung dieser werte immer
gegenwärtig seien kolleginnen und
kollegen der afd wir kennen unsere werte
wir wissen sie wir verteidigen was ihre
werte sind da machen wir hin und wieder
ein fragezeichen dahinter seit gestern
nachmittag macht sich erleichterung
breit innerhalb und außerhalb europas
deutschland hat klar gemacht wenn auch
spät unser platz ist an der seite
unserer bündnispartner
es kann gar nicht anders sein wir
begrüßen deshalb dass die
bundesregierung ihre haltung bei swift
stichwort internationaler
zahlungsverkehr wie auch bei den
waffenlieferungen mit defensiven
charakter aufgegeben hat kolleginnen und
kollegen wir bedauern gleichwohl dass es
hierfür erst eine welle der empörung
gebraucht
wir müssen den mut haben
alles an maßnahmen aufzufahren unterhalb
der schwelle einer eigenen militärischen
auseinandersetzung nicht wir
die ukraine führen einen angriff trägt
aber wir müssen instrumente an hand
geben geeignete instrumente um
zwischenzeitlich auch leben zu schützen
zu verteidigen und größtmöglichen druck
auszuüben es geht darum weiteres leid
und zerstörung zu vermeiden so es
möglich ist ein stopp schild
aufzustellen
wann wenn nicht jetzt kolleginnen und
kollegen es ist unsere pflicht die
ukraine zu unterstützen so bundeskanzler
olaf scholz am gestrigen tag das galt
jedoch schon spätestens zu beginn der
vergangenen woche deshalb zeigen sie
auch weiterhin dass sie den worten
insbesondere des heutigen tages taten
folgen lassen und wir unserer
verantwortung gerecht werden ich sage
ihnen zu dann haben sie uns an ihrer
seite ich schließe mit den worten des
ukrainischen nationaldichter taras
schewtschenko
unser seele unser lied wird nicht
sterben wird nicht verschwinden
darin leute liegt unser rom das lokal
herr botschafter und danke für die
aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank
[Applaus]
als nächste rednerin ruf ich auch die
fraktionsvorsitzende von bündnis 90/die
grünen britta haßelmann
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren
kirche von berlin so weit entfernt wie
rom und ich glaube auch das macht es aus
was es mit uns allen macht und mit den
menschen im land es ist eine unfassbare
tragödie
unsere gedanken sind dort die trauer
schon jetzt über die toten dieses
sinnlosen krieges ist groß bei den
familien bei den angehörigen bei den
freundinnen und freunden bei den
menschen die auf der flucht sind in
großer angst über ihre zukunft und ihre
sicherheit wir alle wissen und können
uns in die lage versetzen was es für uns
alle heißen würde was menschen dort
gerade durchleben und das macht die
tragik und dramatik aus meine danke ich
bin fassungslos wenn ich die bilder sehe
von zerstörten wohnhäuser von menschen
die in schutz den schutz in der u-bahn
wie hier brandenburger tor suchen ja bei
menschen die freunde haben in sorge sind
um ihre angehörigen in der ukraine die
eigentlich alle etwas ganz einfaches
wollen etwas selbstverständlich nämlich
frei und selbstbestimmt zu leben wie wir
alle ich frage mich wirklich jeden tag
was tätig wie ging es mir wie ginge es
meiner familie
wenn ich sehe dass junge menschen sich
bewachen lassen weil sie denken sie
müssen jetzt auch als bürgerinnen und
bürger des landes der ukraine ihren land
verteidigen und für freiheit kämpfen und
daran geht es meine damen und herren und
nicht um fraktion im strauß verdammt
noch mal das ist doch völlig fehlt
dieser debatte
gut
verzweiflung über diesen barbarischen
unmenschlichen krieg und die
ungewissheit und die vielen fragen weil
seit dem 24
februar ist die welt nicht mehr die
gleiche und das spüren die menschen im
land und das sage ich auch in ihre
richtung herr merz wie können sie sich
so lächerlich machen über menschen die
an lichterketten und mahnwachen
teilnehmen wie auch heute wieder überall
im land es ist unser privileg hier zu
sein in deutschland hilft und dort
treten zu dürfen ja über diese lange
aber andere menschen bürgerinnen und
bürger dieses landes sterben vielleicht
nur diese eine ausdrucksform über ihre
verzweiflung ihre besorgnis und ihre
solidarität herr botschafter der ukraine
und das ist vielleicht die teilnahme an
einer lichterkette ich rate ihm sagen
sie so was nie wieder
wir haben eine verantwortung meine damen
und herren und die nehmen wir wahr die
nehmen wir als nationales parlament
europäisch und im transatlantischen
bündnis und
viele gewissheiten die ich habe die
meine fraktion hat gibt alle
demokratischen kräfte in diesem land
haben die sind vielleicht nicht mehr die
gewissheiten die wir noch gestern oder
vor dem 24 februar und wir alle wissen
es verlangt uns wirklich viel ab wir
werden über vieles diskutieren müssen
die welt ist eine andere wir müssen über
den schutz und die aufnahme von
geflüchteten menschen reden und zwar
ohne wenn und aber
denn auch das heißt europa zusammen
stehen für humanitäre hilfe und den
schutz der mensch das ist das was wir
ihnen entgegenbringen können die türen
sind auf und cola und andere das sind
sie weit weg sie sind außerhalb dieses
demokratischen diskurses an dieser
stelle wir führen sind auch in europa
für die menschen weil wir alle könnten
in der gleichen situation seien
angesichts eines solchen eklatanten
bruchs des völkerrechts und das wissen
wir und spüren wir und es gibt eine
bereitschaft bei den bürgerinnen dafür
dass mitzutragen wird zu offen zu sein
dafür und das ist gut wir müssen über
die frage der ernährungssicherung
wir müssen über die energieversorgung
reden und ja wir werden auch über den
verteidigungsetat und die fragen was
notwendig ist reden aber die
entscheidung und der ort der debatte ist
hier ein parlament meine damen und
herren und da bin ich ganz sicher
und ich danke an dieser stelle für die
klare haltung und auf die vorbereitung
der bundesregierung für das harte
sanktionspaket auch die abkopplung von
swift zielgenau war notwendig das
treffen der zentralbank der russischen
wird enorme auswirkungen haben und ich
bin auch der auffassung wie meine
fraktion dass an der stelle die frage
der machen lieferung und des
selbstbestimmungsrechts der ukraine sehr
sehr große bedeutung haben und deshalb
war auch dieser schritt notwendig und
wichtig in dieser schwierigen situation
danke
für dein foto lehmann
[Applaus]
als nächster redner das wort der kollege
peter bistro auf die fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
exzellenz ja
russland führt ein angriffskrieg gegen
die ukraine und wir haben hier sehr viel
über die verantwortung von wladimir
putin an diesen krieg gerat und putin
wird sich auch verantworten müssen vor
den russischen wählern vor den
russischen bürgern aber unsere bürger
wollen wissen welche rolle hat die
deutsche bundesregierung in der
vergangenheit gespielt und wie wird sie
hier jetzt verantworten
und herr bundeskanzler scholz ich habe
in ihren ausführungen die
selbstreflektion vermisst genauso wie
bei der cdu sie haben die letzten acht
jahre regiert sie haben ukraine
finanziert seit acht jahren in
deutschland ist der zweitgrößte
nettozahler und sie haben kein einziges
mal diese zahlungen daran geknüpft dass
die ukraine die minsk zwei abkommen dass
sie das abkommen auch erfüllt und darin
ging es um autonomie es ging lediglich
um autonomie
jetzt ist das vom tisch jetzt ist die
autonomie frage vom tisch jetzt haben
wir krieg und daran tragen sie die
mitverantwortung
sie haben acht jahre lang der ukraine
falsche versprechen gemacht sie haben
sie die in die eu und in die nato
gelockt und jetzt wo der krieg da ist wo
ist denn wo ist denn jetzt ihre
verantwortung sie haben die werte die
demokratie die wollten sie mal mit der
waffe sogar in hindukusch verteidigen
jetzt ist der krieg in europa jetzt
kennen sich in vereinen verteidigen und
was machen sie gar nichts sie haben
ukraine immer nur als spielball auf der
geopolitischen karte missbraucht ihr
ganzes wert der geräte war pure
heuchelei und
was was jetzt kommen sie mir nicht mit
den sanktionen ich bitte sie die russen
haben die sanktionen mit eingepreist ich
sagen ich will das ja gar nicht zitieren
was botschafter in schweden gesagt hat
und dass herr lindner gesagt hat
schulden sind freiheit das sagte man
damals an der liberalen partei war also
liebe freunde schulden sind die freiheit
schulden sind knechtschaft jeder eurer
von und diesen 100 milliarden die sie
rausgehen werden werden arbeitenden
bürgern in deutschland über steuern
abgepresst
so was haben sie erreicht sie haben das
gesagt herr bundeskanzler scholz die
einflusssphäre hat sich verschoben ja
welche einfluss wäre die nato hat sich
verschoben an die grenzen russland die
amerikanische einflusssphäre hat sich
richtung russische grenze verschoben und
was ist der preis dafür junge männer
sterben es in ukraine genauso wie russen
sterben jetzt und geopolitisch haben sie
russland in die hände von china
getrieben russland war immer eine
europäische macht und sie haben sie in
die umarmung von china getrieben
und sagen sie nicht sie waren nicht
gewarnt es warten genauso die russen
schon vor 15 jahren wladimir putin hat
hier gesprochen im deutschen bundestag
damals wurde beklatscht er hat 2007 bei
der siko in münchen gesprochen hat uns
eine gemeinsame sicherheitsarchitektur
angeboten und sie haben das alles
ausgeschlagen ihre eigene leute haben
sie gewarnt admiral schönbach noch vor
einem monat das alles haben sie
ausgeschlagen sie haben alle warnungen
ignoriert und das ergebnis ist krieg in
europa und dafür tragen auch sie eine
mitverantwortung
[Applaus]
liebe kollegen kollegen auch solche
reden zeigen den unterschied zwischen
einem parlament in freiheit und ein paar
land in freiheit
als nächster redner hält das wort der
ministerpräsident des landes brandenburg
dr
sehr geehrter herr präsident
verehrte abgeordnete dass ich mal an
einer stelle stehe und sage dass die
brandenburger auf die fraktion beispiel
gebend war fast die
verurteilung des überfalls russlands auf
die ukraine betrifft das hätte ich mir
vor wenigen minuten noch nicht
vorstellen können aber nach dem was hier
gesagt worden ist muss ich das leider
sagen es ist ein skandal wie sie von der
fdp fraktion mit dieser krise umgehen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
nach jahrzehnten des krieges nach
jahrzehnten des friedens gibt es wieder
krieg in europa es ist eine tragödie für
die menschen in der ukraine
es bringt leid es bringt tod es ist aber
auch eine tragödie für die menschen in
russland wir erleben einen eklatanten
bruch des völkerrechts wir erleben den
versuch den lauf der geschichte mit
tieren mit militärischen mitteln zu
verändern und wir erleben den versuch
die demokratische entwicklung in einem
unabhängigen land mit
militärischer gewalt zu verhindern
es ist ein
verbrecherischer krieg den der russische
präsident vom zaun gebrochen hat es ist
ein krieg gegen
die demokratie und gegen die freiheit
und meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren es ist ein krieg gegen uns alle
viele stehen fest an der seite der
ukraine
diese aggression wird ihre ziele nicht
erreichen nicht in der ukraine aber auch
nicht in europa die menschen in
deutschland die menschen in brandenburg
wollen frieden wir wollen freundschaft
mit anderen völkern
besonders auch mit dem russischen volk
viele die sich in den letzten
jahrzehnten für gute beziehung zu
russland beispielsweise in schule
städtepartnerschaften bei wirtschafts
oder sport projekten eingesetzt haben
sind heute tief enttäuscht verbittert
und frustriert und ich gebe zu das
betrifft auch mich persönlich
hätte mir noch vor wenigen wochen nicht
vorstellen können dass am 24 februar
dieses jahres realität geworden ist auch
ich wenn tief enttäuscht von dem was in
den letzten tagen passiert ist aber ich
glaube gerade in dieser schweren zeit
ist es notwendig die menschen zu
ermuntern sich weiterhin für starke
kontakte in die russische
zivilgesellschaft
einzusetzen es ist eben nicht
das russische volk das pik in der
ukraine führt es ist ein präsident
der mit seiner clique diesen krieg vom
zaun gebrochen hat und deswegen müssen
wir weiter versuchen auch wenn es
schwierig wird und wenn es schwierig ist
brücken zu bauen denn wenn diese brücken
nicht gebaut werden hat präsident putin
gewonnen meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren ich habe mich in den letzten
tagen häufig an eine veranstaltung am
dritten beides jahres 2009 10 in bad
freienwalde erinnert ich habe damals mit
seiner exzellenz dem russischen
botschafter eine neu gestaltete
gedenkstätte für sowjetische opfer des
zweiten weltkrieges eingeweiht das
besondere an dieser gedenkstätte ist das
1400 gefallene ihren namen und ihre
geburtsdaten
zurückbekommen haben
1400 gefallene soldaten in unserer daten
der damaligen sowjetischen armee die mit
diesen daten ihre identität zurück
bekommen haben sie haben ihren namen
zurückbekommen und mit dem namen wird
jedem klar es liegt eben tier nicht der
unbekannte soldat so es liegt hier andré
rotter ivan
oder alexy
und jeder
einzelne von ihnen war ein sohn ein
bruder ein ehemann
und ein freund
und wenige von den 1400 die in bad
freienwalde beerdigt worden sind waren
älter als
20 jahre
und genau jetzt genau heute genau zu
dieser stunde
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
sterben wieder menschen in einem krieg
und diese toten in bad freienwalde auch
an vielen anderen stellen die 25
millionen toten die die sowjetunion als
blutzoll im zweiten weltkrieg zu
bezahlen hatte mahnen uns heute sie
fordern den russischen präsidenten auf
sie rufen ihm zu nie wieder krieg auch
im namen der menschen die im zweiten
weltkrieg gestorben ist herr präsident
putin
stoppen sie sofort die aggression gegen
die ukraine stoppen sie das morgen
stoppen sie den krieg dann gesehen
vielen dank herr ministerpräsident
für diese worte
nächsten dass der kollege durch dr
johann wadephul cdu csu fraktion
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen
kollegen glaube genau herr
ministerpräsident in der tonalität
sollten wir auch die debatte miteinander
führen sie hat gezeigt dass es richtig
ist in dieser situation zusammenzustehen
der bundeskanzler hat dazu heute eine
bemerkenswerte rede gehalten das ist ein
geopolitischer amoklauf den präsidenten
putin hier veranstaltet und dem müssen
wir uns in der mitte des hauses
gemeinsam
entgegenstellen und
die debatte hat erneut gezeigt dass
links und rechts in diesem haus
parlamentarier und parlamentarier sitzen
die ihrer aufgabe nicht gerecht werden
sie muss insbesondere sagen was wir hier
an stimmen aus der fdp fraktion heute
wieder gehört haben
schlägt dem fass den boden aus es ist
widerlich anhören zu müssen dass sie
angesichts dieses angriffskrieges sogar
in der bundesregierung eine
mitverantwortung sehen wollen angesichts
der begründung die der russische
präsident für seinen angriff ski gibt
gegeben hat es müsse eine
entnazifizierung in der ukraine
stattfinden die von einem präsidenten
mit jüdischer abstammung geführt wird
das ist an perfidie nicht zu überbieten
und wir müssen zusammenstehen als
demokratinnen und demokraten damit
solche leute
wieder verantwortung übernehmen
und wir müssen gemeinsam handeln und das
ist genau das und deswegen glaube ich
auch wir sind alle aufgefordert hier
gemeinsam zusammenzustehen auch in der
mitte des hauses und es hat ja ein
nachhaltiger aufforderung in unsere
richtung gegeben das zu machen die cdu
csu fraktion ist im geiste der
bisherigen beratungen dazu bereit und
ich schlage vor frau kollegin
dass wir hier an der stelle uns auch
nicht auseinander trennen und es ist
genau das was friedrich merz auch heute
angeboten hat und dass wir natürlich
machen ohne aufgabe unserer
parlamentarischen oppositionellen rechte
wir kennen uns ja aus vielen jahren wo
sie hier als
wirklich strikte war nehmerin auch von
oppositionellen rechten aufgetreten sind
die cdu deutschlands hat gestern unter
hat friedrich merz gesprochen eine
mahnwache gehalten und das hat er hier
heute als gut befunden
der punkt ist der punkt ist ja deswegen
will ich mal ganz ehrlich sagen war es
absolut daneben uns so etwas vorzuwerfen
wenn man so etwas einem nicht vorwerfen
kann ist der cdu unter führung von
friedrich merz
betrifft ist nur wir müssen eben
gemeinsamen handeln
und einen großen handlungsstark bereich
im bereich der verteidigungspolitik hat
der herr bundeskanzler angesprochen und
hat hier das wort besucher passt jetzt
an der stelle nicht weil das haben sie
an anderer stelle mal benutzt und ich
will es ausdrücklich nicht verwenden
aber für die bundeswehr eine finanzielle
ausstattung zugesagt zwei prozent wird
niemals mehr unterschritten werden und
100 milliarden in einem sondervermögen
das ist eine große ansagen und darüber
können wir miteinander reden nur mir
fällt auf dass außer dem
fraktionsvorsitz in der freien
demokraten bisher keine
parteivorsitzende und kein
parteivorsitzender und kein
fraktionsvorsitzender der spd aus den
koalitionsfraktionen dieser ankündigung
begrüßt und unterstützt hat das fällt
mir auf liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und die zurückhaltung in der grünen
fraktion die zurückhaltung in der grünen
fraktion als der herr bundeskanzler
genau das gesagt hat die es schon sehr
auffällig gewesen sie haben uns bei sich
wenn wir jetzt geschlossene reagieren
sie haben uns bei sich wenn es um die
aufnahme von flüchtlingen geht aber wir
müssen auch zusammenstehen wenn es
konkret wird und nicht dass es wieder
losgeht mit gruppenanträge benzin wenn
es um die förderung der bundeswehr und
den verteidigungsetat geht da brauchen
wir brauchen sie ihre eigene mehrheit da
verlangen wir von ihnen dass sie stehen
ja ich kann es nicht anders sagen es gab
zahlreiche fans denn es gab zahlreiche
reden herr kollege mütze nicht das hätte
man alles sagen können dass sie das
hundertprozentig unterstützen wir warten
darauf bitte schön machen sie es und ich
will etwas zum thema abschreckung sagen
ein kollege mit sichtweise sich da das
haben sie heute nicht wiederholt aber in
vergangener zeit schon dazu eingelassen
haben das ist nicht schön aber
abschreckung ist leider notwendig damit
man nicht erst in diese moralischen
abwägungen hineinkommt die robert habeck
jetzt bei der frage der waffenlieferung
hier sehr treffend heute umschrieben hat
das verrückte ist das perfide ist doch
dass die ukraine jetzt dafür bestraft
wird dass sie 1994 nuklear waffen
abgegeben hat und diese rechnung darf
doch nicht aufgehen und deswegen darf
man doch nicht herr kollege müssen jetzt
möchte ich sagen in aller freundschaft
die wir auch immer den politischen
diskurs miteinander führen deswegen kann
man sich doch nicht hinstellen und sagen
nukleare abschreckung funktioniert nicht
leider funktioniert sie doch und
deswegen brauchen wir deutschen sie
deswegen braucht die nato auch die
nukleare abschreckung damit wir den
russen nicht ausgeliefert sind und da
wird es jetzt sehr konkret werden und da
müssen wir sie daran und da sind wir mit
sicherheit das hat der fraktionsvorsitz
für meine fraktion angekündigt da sind
wir der meinung über alles kann man
reden auch über sonderfonds natürlich
aber dann muss es ein gesamtkonzept
geben was insbesondere die bundeswehr
betrifft dass wir auch eingebunden
werden einen blankoscheck der
cdu/csu-fraktion den sie daran irgendwie
verwenden wird es nicht geben sondern
wir verlangen einbezogen zu werden in
die diskussion
und wenn wir so gemeinsam handeln meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren kann ein
möglicher militärischer sieg der putin
vielleicht gelingen könnte wir hoffen
dass alle nicht so leer und muss er in
jedem fall ein pyrrhussieg werden dieser
mann muss sich verantworten nicht nur
vor dem russischen volk kolleginnen und
kollegen der ard sondern vor dem
internationalen strafgerichtshof da
gehört er hin herzlichen dank
vielen dank herr kollege
und wiederholen
nächster redner der kollege rüdiger
lukas auf die fraktion von der tribüne
[Applaus]
herr präsident sehr geehrte kollegen die
atommacht russland hat die ukraine
angegriffen ein militärischer sieg
putins ist wir sehr wahrscheinlich zu
einem enorm hohen preis was kommt dann
ein land doppelt so groß wie deutschland
im guerillakrieg repressionen terror
dauerhafte die stabilisierung an der
ostgrenze der eu dramatische aussichten
viele von ihnen wünschen sich eine
niederlage putins ich auch aber was käme
dann einsicht rückkehr in die
internationale gemeinschaft übergabe der
macht an einen friedlichen nachfolger
unvorstellbar putin ist all in gegangen
verliert er kann er erst recht kann es
erst recht zu einem albtraum werden
aufstand des russischen volkes aufstand
des militärs machtkampf im staatsapparat
eine niederlage putins ist
unkalkulierbar weil russland atommacht
ist meine damen und herren wir haben
eine historische chance verpasst
europa und wir deutsche armes nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg nicht geschafft eine
friedensordnung zu bauen die russland
integriert 1990 bekamen wir dazu eine
zweite chance auch die haben wir nicht
genutzt putin hat uns angebote gemacht
wir sind aber nicht darauf eingegangen
wir haben es nicht vermocht das
sicherheitsinteresse der russischen
föderation zu verstehen und zu
akzeptieren
wir haben die ihnen geglaubt die es
bewusst nicht verstehen wollten jetzt
ist es dafür zu spät jetzt haben wir
wieder krieg mitten in europa einen
angriffskrieg der durch nichts zu
entschuldigen ist auch nicht durch die
ignoranz des westens in den letzten 25
jahren
was heißt das für deutschland wir sind
hart auf dem boden der realität
aufgeschlagen die brutale politik der
macht ist zurück und fegt die
gesinnungsethik aus der deutschen
politik deutschland hat keine
alternative die bundesregierung muss nun
auch das steuer in richtung machtpolitik
herumreißen macht heißt auch
militärische fähigkeiten zu besitzen
deutschland hat diese fähigkeit nicht
mehr jeder hier im hause weiß dass die
bundeswehr kann unser land nicht
verteidigen und sie kann deutschlands
verpflichtungen im bündnis nicht
nachkommen was wir jetzt brauchen ist
die größte
rüstungszwecke
das lässt sich nicht in einem jahr
bewerkstelligen auch nicht mit den
tatsächlich erforderlichen 100
milliarden aber die bundesregierung ist
auch dafür verantwortlich das
bewusstsein für eine neue wehrhaftigkeit
in unserem volk zu schärfen meine damen
und herren die wehrpflicht in
deutschland muss reaktiviert werden wann
wenn nicht jetzt wehrhaftigkeit ist der
preis unser freiheitlich danken
vielen dank herr kollege lukas nächste
rednerin ist die kollegin gabriele
heinrich spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren lieber kollege wadephul ich
glaube wir brauchen die schärfe in der
diskussion nicht und ich finde es aber
schwierig jemanden vorzuwerfen was er in
seiner rede nicht gesagt hat weil sie
natürlich eine andere sensibilisierung
an der stelle haben wir werden
miteinander um den haushalt diskutieren
und wir werden dahin kommen was wir alle
miteinander wollen nämlich die
bundeswehr zu stärken
jetzt bin ich zum thema zurück der
angriff auf die ukraine eine historische
zäsur es wurde heute schon häufig gesagt
dieser angriff hat die europäische
friedensordnung zerstört dieser wahnsinn
diese von pretty präsident putin
vorangetriebene eskalation der von ihm
selbst geschaffenen krise macht
fassungslos und schockiert und wir sind
schockiert aber nicht in schockstarre
der westen ist vorbereitet und er ist
mehr gemeint denn wir alle stehen in
diesen dramatischen tagen an der seite
der ukraine das streben der ukrainer und
ukrainerinnen
nach demokratie nach freiheit nach
selbstbestimmung ist ein menschenrecht
und das ist nicht vom wohlwollen eines
präsidenten putin abhängig
wir trauern um die toten die verletzten
die männer frauen und kinder der ukraine
die diesem sinnlosen leid ausgesetzt
sind und die so viel angst haben
die menschen in der ukraine brauchen
jetzt uns humanitär durch aufnahme der
flüchtlinge durch druck gegen das
russische regime die politisch
verantwortlichen und diejenigen die
diesen verbrecherischen überfall
ermöglichen auch die militärische
unterstützung der ukraine ist nunmehr
folgerichtig
meine damen und herren deutschland und
seine verbündeten haben lange den weg
der diplomatie gewählt und mit ihnen das
gespräch um die zusammenarbeit angeboten
das wohl von vielen seiten auch im
nachhinein als naiv kritisiert aber für
den versuch über gespräche und
diplomatie
eskalation zu vermeiden und zu beenden
werden wir uns niemals schämen
auch in der wirkliche präsident dieses
angebot auf brutale weise ausgeschlagen
hat allein er hat es jetzt in der hand
diesen irrweg zu verlassen das töten zu
beenden
meine damen und herren dieser brutale
überfall ist aufwuchs eines verqueren
welt wird es einer absurden
interpretation der geschichte und eines
imperialismus den wir für überwunden
halten mit seinem vorgehen und seiner
rhetorik knüpft wladimir putin an die
dunklen zeiten der russischen und
sowjetischen geschichte an sein vorgehen
reiht sich ein in seinen kampf gegen all
diejenigen die eine echte aufarbeitung
der russisch sowjetischen geschichte und
des stalinismus wurden
deshalb hat er die
menschenrechtsorganisation memorial
aufgelöst und das war nur einer von so
vielen angriffen auf die lebendige
humanistische erinnerungskultur und die
menschenrechte in russland
es reiht sich ein in immer autoritäre
tendenzen innerhalb russlands und immer
enger werdende freiräume für
menschenrechtsaktivisten und die zügige
gesellschaft und umso mehr beeindrucken
die proteste gegen den krieg die wir in
vielen städten russland sehen der mut
dieser oft jungen menschen gegen
autokratie und für den frieden
aufzustehen der kann gar nicht genug
bewundert werden das risiko behaftet zu
werden oder sogar zu verschwinden ist
immens gestiegen aber alle mittel der
repression werden nichts nützen die
mittel des krieges und der unterdrückung
die der menschenverachtende aggressor
wladimir putin gewählt hat werden sich
auf dauer nicht durchsetzen davon bin
ich überzeugt vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner ist der kollege dirk
wiese spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident kolleginnen
und kollegen seine exzellenz botschafter
meldung dieser krieg ist putins krieg
dieser angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine
ist völkerrechtswidrig eine schande und
in keiner weise zu rechtfertigen vor
allem nicht historisch er ist real und
findet in unserer nachbarschaft statt
die zeichen waren da die truppen standen
bereit warum haben wir punkten denn noch
unterschätzt weil wir vielleicht unsere
analyse zu sehr auf die vermeintlichen
rationalität der akteure gestützt haben
wir die kaltblütigkeit und die
imperialistischen und revisionistischen
großmacht gedanken putins unterschätzt
haben wir vielleicht ist auch nicht
wahrhaben wollten dabei ist putins krieg
die fortsetzung der völkerrechtswidrigen
annexion der krim er ist die fortsetzung
der kriegerischen auseinandersetzungen
in der ost ukraine nicht zu vergessen
die verletzung der territorialen
integrität von georgiern er ist auf das
schärfste zu verurteilen und eine
sackgasse jedweder auseinandersetzung
putin
putin bringt fürchterliches leid über
die menschen in der ukraine
ihnen gilt unsere uneingeschränkte
solidarität ihnen und den mutigen
russinnen und russen die in diesen
stunden aufbegehren gegen ein
autoritäres und despotisches regime
ihnen die in kenntnis von polizeigewalt
und repressalien in russland trotzdem
für den frieden auf die straßen gehen
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
dieser russische angriffskrieg wird auch
massive auswirkungen auf die
sicherheitslage in deutschland und auf
fluchtbewegungen in europa haben hierauf
bereiten wir uns vor und wir werden
denjenigen die schutz bei uns suchen
helfen unsere sicherheitsbehörden
haben sich bereits intensiv auf alle
denkbaren szenarien vorbereitet und
schutzmaßnahmen hochgefahren ich bin
bundesinnenministerium feser dankbar
dass sie bereits mit den
landesinnenministern in einem sehr engen
austausch steht und sich auf
europäischer ebene eng mit unseren
verbündeten koordiniert auch jetzt in
diesen stunden ich bin auch unseren
städten und gemeinden dankbar
stellvertretend für viele dem arzberger
bürgermeister ralf paul wittner die
bereits klar zum ausdruck gebracht haben
dass die ukraine den ukrainer aufnehmen
wollen die vor dem russischen
angriffskrieg aus ihrem heimatland
fliehen muss kinder
kinder die sich unter tränen von ihren
vätern verabschiedet haben frau ihren
mann vielleicht zum letzten mal in die
arme genommen haben und dieses leid ist
kennt nur eine adresse die verantwortung
dafür liegt im kreml und ich sage es
auch sehr deutlich auch für die trauer
der russischen mütter ihre jungen söhne
nur im zinksarg nach hause bekommt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
müssen zwar zuerst von flucht und
vertreibung 's bewegungen innerhalb der
ukraine ausgehen sie haben sich aber
bereits jetzt zu den vergangenen 72
stunden auf die unmittelbaren
nachbarländer wie polen oder die
republik moldau ausgeweitet sie haben
unsere solid solidarität und unsere
humanitäre unterstützung und wir werden
sie massiv unterstützen die
koordinations und unterstützungs
mechanismen der europäischen union
insbesondere für humanitäre hilfe sind
bereits angelaufen damit ganz konkrete
unterstützung sehr schnell erfolgt und
dazu wird deutschland einen erheblichen
beitrag leisten wir wissen auch dass
cyber angriffe mittlerweile ein häufiges
mittel in konfliktsituationen sind und
wir gehen daher auch für deutsche
stellen von einer erhöhten gefahr durch
cyber-angriffe in der nächsten zeit aus
wir beobachten auch sehr genau dass die
russische propaganda und desinformation
im zuge des ukraine konflikt deutlich
zunimmt bei russia today by telegramm
bei demonstrationen aber auch auf
sogenannten spaziergänge wir müssen uns
auf ein weiter auf zunehmendes ausmaß an
fortwährender desinformation einstellen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen unsere
antwort ist und bleibt freiheit
internationale solidarität und
demokratie der platz für
kriegsverbrecher ist und bleibt hingegen
in den haag und nirgendwo sonst vielen
dank für die aufmerksamkeit
dank natürliche wiese
nächsten dass der fraktionslose kollege
johannes huber er spricht von der 1
klein klar und das mikro scheint nicht
zu funktionieren
sehr geehrter herr präsident jetzt ist
das mikro an ihre exzellenz liebe
mitbürger der völkerrechtswidrige
angriffskrieg von vladimir putin gegen
die souveräne nation ukraine ist durch
nichts zu rechtfertigen weder durch den
ebenfalls völkerrechtswidrigen angriff
der nato auf jugoslawien noch durch die
nato osterweiterung auf ehemaligen
staaten des warschauer paktes die dem
bündnis aus freier selbstbestimmung
beigetreten sind der gewählte
ukrainische präsident selensky hatte dem
deutschen bundeskanzler und dem
französischen präsidenten in den letzten
wochen fest zugesagt dass er drei
gesetzte im ukrainischen parlament
initiieren wird und das münchner
abkommen vollständig umzusetzen
der diplomatische korridor war also noch
nicht ausgeschöpft das wusste auch putin
er wollte aber die beiden volksrepublik
nicht wieder in die ukraine integrieren
sondern diese friedensordnung mit der
einseitigen anerkennung der
unabhängigkeit der gesamten gebiet
donezk und lohans bewusst aufkündigen
das ist auch keine rechtfertigung für
den überfall auf die gesamte ukraine
sondern für putin das mittel zum zweck
um die ukrainische regierung gewaltsam
und in den bau unter inkaufnahme von
zahlreichen kriegstoten und flüchtlingen
zu stürzen und zur sicherung seiner
eigenen autorität im eigenen land durch
eine gehörige regierung zu ersetzen bis
dieses ziel erreicht ist da dürfen wir
uns nichts vormachen werden die
kampfhandlungen nicht eingestellt und
die truppen später zur sicherung der
künftigen regierung nicht zurückgezogen
auch eine vermittlung von deutschland
und frankreich sieht putin mittlerweile
eher als einmischung das regime putin
muss daher nicht nur mit
personenbezogenen sanktionen gestoppten
isoliert werden sondern auch mit einer
militärischen abschreckung das bedeutet
dass auch deutschland nicht um eine
schnelle und massive ertüchtigung der
bundeswehr sowie einer wehrpflicht auch
zur verteidigung des eigenen landes
herum kommt schließlich droht ihm offen
mit einem flächenbrand in dem er manöver
in moldau und georgien abhält jegliche
ausländische truppen aus den 14 neuen
mitgliedsstaaten der nato vertreiben
will schweden und finnland droht in
bosnien einfluss zur spaltung ausübt und
sich als ehemaliger kgb offizier in der
ddr das geopolitische wiederaufleben der
sowjetunion wünscht herr präsident ich
schließe mit meiner hoffnung die jetzt
bei den unschuldigen russischen bürgern
die mit der politik putins nicht
einverstanden sind sie haben jetzt die
chance dafür zu sorgen dass putin jahr
2024 nicht mehr als präsident
wiedergewählt wird vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege
als nächste gerät dann hat das wort die
kollegin sony ab die spd fraktion
[Applaus]
seit der präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen in den letzten tagen fiel es
mir schwer worte für die aktuellen
ereignisse zu finden der brutale angriff
russlands wird in erster linie auf dem
rücken der ukrainischen
zivilgesellschaft ausgetragen putin
nimmt den menschen in der ukraine die
hoffnung auf ein leben in frieden
rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratie auch
aus entwicklungspolitischer perspektive
steht derzeit eine menge auf dem spiel
gemeinsam mit unseren ukrainischen
partnern haben wir in den letzten jahren
fortschritte und veränderungen erzielt
ein maßgebliches projekt im rahmen
dieser zusammenarbeit sind die
partnerschaften zwischen deutschen und
ukrainischen kommunen diese strukturen
erweisen sich in krisenzeiten als eine
effektive verbindung zur ukrainischen
bevölkerung
durch unsere unterstützung haben wir
gemeinsam viel erreicht in den bereichen
bildung energie infrastruktur und den
guter regierungsführung viele
nichtregierungsorganisationen und die
politischen stiftungen haben dazu
beigetragen eine starke demokratie vcn
zivilgesellschaft in der ukraine
aufzubauen all das wird durch putins
krieg zerstört
meine gedanken sind dabei auch bei den
nationalen mitarbeiter in der
entwicklungspolitischen organisationen
die diese erfolge erst möglich gemacht
haben ich bin dankbar dass die
organisation mit hochdruck daran
arbeiten die sicherheit ihrer nationalen
mitarbeiterin zu gewährleisten und sie
auch finanziell zu unterstützen
aber auch die breite bevölkerung braucht
nun akute humanitäre unterstützung
hierzu brauchen wir flexibilität bei der
bereitstellung der finanziellen mittel
ich möchte noch auf einen weiteren punkt
aufmerksam machen der russische angriff
kann auch gravierende auswirkungen auf
die länder des globalen südens haben die
ukraine ist ein großer globaler
exporteur von getreide länder die
ägypten libyen geben
[Musik]
importieren große mengen an ukrainischen
weizen ein jetzt zu erwartende
verknappung der lebensmittelversorgung
erhöhte preise können einen dominoeffekt
auslösen
innerstaatliche konflikte kann verstärkt
oder neu angefacht werden und dies alles
vor dem hintergrund der durch corona
ohnehin bedingten wirtschaftlichen
notlage in den ländern des globalen
südens ich vertraue der bundesregierung
auf diesen blick zu haben
mein tiefster respekt geht den menschen
die nun in sankt petersburg und in
moskau trotz der gefahren auf die
straßen gehen um sich mit der ukraine zu
solidarisieren bereite im
internationalen druck der auf putin ein
wird zeigt sich am meisten angst hat
dieser mann vor seiner eigenen
zivilgesellschaft von menschen die sich
nur frieden rechtsstaatlichkeit und
demokratie einsetzen daran sehen wir wie
wichtig eine starke zivilgesellschaft
ist ich bin froh dass der bundeskanzler
auch die notwendigkeit der krisen
präventiven entwicklungspolitik in
seiner rede betont hat das heißt dass
0,7 prozent oder ziel müssen wir in
zukunft dauerhaft einheiten
verteidigungspolitik geht nur hand in
hand mit entwicklungspolitik denn
entwicklungspolitik ist friedenspolitik
denke
vielen dank frau politiker die
als nächster redner das wort der kollege
dr matthias miersch spd fraktion
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben uns in der spd
bundestagsfraktion als fachpolitiker
jetzt aufgeteilt weil einige punkte
sicherlich auch hier näher beleuchtet
werden müssen deswegen will ich sagen
das was olaf scholz heute als
zeitenwende bezeichnet hat betrifft auch
die klima- und energiepolitik und dazu
in der gebotenen kürze vier punkte die
aus meiner sicht in den nächsten wochen
monaten und jahren essentiell sein
werden erstens wir müssen die zukünftige
energie und klimapolitik als elementaren
bestandteil von daseinsvorsorge sehen in
diesem haus liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
dazu gehört ein
bundeswirtschaftsminister wie sie
zurecht gesagt haben dass die frage von
speicherung keine thematik von
privatwirtschaftlichen interessen sein
darf sondern ein hoheitlicher aufgaben
gehört liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
dazu gehört auch dass wir das thema
energiepreise aus dem blickwinkel der
daseinsvorsorge
betrachten energie muss für wirtschaft
und weite teile dieser bevölkerung
bezahlbar bleiben dafür müssen wir als
staat garantieren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das
zweite energie souveränität geht nur
durch einen weg und das ist der maximale
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien und ich
bin ausgesprochen dankbar dass sowohl
der bundeskanzler der
bundeswirtschaftsminister und der
bundesfinanzminister hier ein deutliches
votum abgegeben haben dass der maximale
ausbau unserer aufgabe nummer eins sein
muss liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und während kollege merz wenn sie dann
von optionen in der energiepolitik reden
dann spüre ich das was ich die letzten
jahre leider in dieser großen koalition
gespürt habe sie haben leider keinen
inneren kompass wenn sie meinen dass
atomkraft weiter eine alternative sein
soll dann sage ich ihnen wir sehen doch
jetzt bei tschernobyl wir sehen bei den
alten reaktoren und die verwundbarkeit
von staaten dass diese technologie nie
eine alternative mehr sein darf liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
der vierte punkt und der ist der
schwierigste für mich auch als
klimapolitiker
das pariser abkommen gilt weiter
dieser planet
ist zu klein als dass wir es
gegeneinander hinkriegen würden wir
werden alle staaten brauchen wir werden
nur es zu sammeln können und deswegen
hoffe ich dass die diplomatie auch in
dieser frage siegen wird vielen dank für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank herr kollege
von mir
als nächstes jahr das wort der kollege
dr nils schmid spd fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren lassen sie nicht mit
einer persönlichen bemerkung beginnen im
september 1989 habe ich an einem
schüleraustausch und dem ersten
schüleraustausch einer westdeutschen
stadt mit unterbringung in
familien teilgenommen mit der stadt
poltawa damals sowjetischen
republik rheine
damit gehört einer generation an die in
den letzten 30 jahren versucht hat die
beiden hälften des kontinents enger
zusammenzubringen über schüleraustausch
über wirtschaftliche
zivilgesellschaftliche verflechtung
natürlich auch über viele politische
weichenstellungen wie sie in den letzten
30 jahren über abrüstungsverträge
kooperationsverträge und ähnliches zu
stande gekommen sind eine generation 89
sozusagen die in politik gesellschaft
wirtschaft und medien in den letzten 30
jahren sich da dafür eingesetzt hat dass
wir in ost und west im ganzen kontinent
ein friedliches miteinander eine gesamte
europäische friedensordnung aufbauend
auf demokratie und freiheit schaffen und
mit dem angriffskrieg von putin auf die
ukraine ist nicht nur eine zeitenwende
eingetreten es ist auch das ende der
hoffnung einer ganzen generation die
nicht 68 nicht von der
nachrüstungsdebatte geprägt ist sondern
eben von der zeitenwende 89 und dem
aufbruch hin zu unseren osteuropäischen
partnern und deshalb ist dieses ereignis
dieser einschnitt in uns europäischen
geschichte so bitter für viele aus
meiner generation
und wir spüren ganz genau
was es jetzt auch bedeutet für das
praktische außenpolitische handeln war
bisher die st dialog und abschreckung
die parole wird es doch wieder mehr
abschreckung und dialog sein
und in der vergangenheit in den letzten
30 jahren hatten wir drei elemente wie
wir es geschafft haben den europäischen
kontinent zusammenzubringen gemeinsame
regeln im rahmen der osze der
wirtschaftliche austausch und die
verflechtung und die zivilgesellschaft
all diese drei elemente werden wir auch
noch in zukunft brauchen wir sollten
gemeinsam mit deutschen bundestag dafür
kämpfen diese kanäle gerade auch nach
russland aufrechtzuerhalten aber sie
werden deutlich weniger bedeutung haben
sie werden zum teil werden wir die
wirtschaft und schauen fast keine
bedeutung mehr in zukunft haben können
und deshalb ist es jetzt wichtig nicht
nur heute zu sagen und kurzfristig über
waffenlieferungen oder ähnliches zu
reden sondern müssen uns darauf
einstellen dass wir in einer anderen
politik mischung mit russland in den
nächsten jahren umgehen müssen das eben
abschreckung stärker wird und leider die
elemente die wir die 30 letzten jahre
gepflegt haben weniger bedeutsam werden
das residence deutlich wichtiger wird
und dass wir vor einer daueraufgabe
stehen diese russische herausforderung
die sie putin uns formuliert hat
wirklich zu bestehen und trotzdem und
das soll mein appell zum schluss sein
lassen sie uns die wenigen dialog kanäle
gerade auch nach russland in die
gesellschaft hinein nicht aufgeben denn
es wird auch in russland nach putting
dem herzlichen dank
vielen dank herr kollege mit
nächster redner ist der kollege wolfgang
hänisch spd fraktion
[Applaus]
der präsident sehr verehrte kolleginnen
kollegen
putin hat mit einem verbrecherischen
angriffskrieg die europäische
friedensordnung zerstört
er gleichzeitig uns alle bedroht im
laufe der letzten jahre haben wir
gesehen wie waffen potenziale aufgebaut
worden sind den hier wirkung bis tief
nach europa hineinreichen und das was in
den letzten tagen im zuge dieses
angriffskriege sehen an drohungen
gegenüber ganz europa muss uns besorgt
machen weil im blick hat er nicht nur
die ukraine sondern uns alle im blick
selbst unsere werteordnung dick unsere
gesellschaften den blick wert die
menschen im blick und nicht nur im blick
sondern im visier und das ist ein punkt
der uns tief besorgt machen müssen
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass wir
gerade in transatlantischen bündnis der
nato unsere fähigkeit noch ausbauen und
stärken in uns gegen diese bedrohung
schützen zu können essentiell für unsere
existenz und es ist essenziell für den
frieden auch in dieser welt dinge wieder
gewinnen wollen denn der eine schafft
putin nicht und da sehen wir in tiflis
das sehen wir in der ukraine das sehen
wir in russland das sehen den vielen
europäischen städten den willen der
menschen zum frieden den kann er nicht
brechen das wird er mit schatten
und deshalb ist es so wichtig dass er in
dieser situation von hier aus von der
demonstration gleich von vielen anderen
stellen auch die botschaft überbringen
dass wir an der seite der menschen
stehen die sich dort den widerstand
befinden und deshalb ist es so wichtig
dass in dieser situation aufwachen die
hunte gibt ihnen die ukraine geliefert
werden damit die menschen dort in der
lage sind ihr leben zu verteidigen land
zu verteidigen ihre freiheit und ihr
recht zu verteidigen
und richtig bedanke ich mich herzlich
bei der bundesregierung auf bei dem
bundeskanzler in dieser situation auch
deutlich zu machen dass wir unsere
fähigkeiten in der nato stärken und
ausbauen werden dass wir unsere beiträge
liefern werden und dass wir verlässlich
sind unsere soldatinnen soldaten die
gerade in der nato ihren dienst versehen
die im laufe der letzten tage sich auf
diesen auch auf den weg gemacht haben um
die nato zu steht nun doch deutlich zu
machen wir stehen für unsere
bündnispartner so wie wir von unseren
bündnispartnern erwarten dass sie für
uns ein stehen das werden wir
vollumfänglich erfüllen und der wade
pool ich würde einen sagen wir gehen
jetzt in den maschinenraum der
parlamentarischen arbeit um das was
angekündigt worden ist das was auf den
tisch legt auch entsprechend umzusetzen
damit zügig und soldatinnen soldaten das
was ihnen zugesagt worden ist hier
zugesagt worden ist dann auch zügig auf
dem hof auf dem manga und auch in der
werte liegen haben nicht unser werk
sondern dem hafen und sie damit umgehen
können deshalb herzlichen dank an unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten die sehr wohl
bewusst wissen welche verantwortung auf
die zukunft und an welcher stelle sie
gerade ihren eid nämlich das land tapfer
zu verteidigen
auch umsetzen meinen herzlichen dank
dafür bestehe nicht in ihrer seite wir
unterstützen hierbei und helfen zu
wickeln vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege mich
jetzt regnen diese debatte ist der
kollege frank schwabe spd fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen maria
menzel war lisa jasko wolodimir arif und
julia lokschina das sind kolleginnen und
kollegen der parlamentarischen
versammlung des europarats und
mitglieder des ukrainischen parlaments
und ich bin in kontinuierlichen kontakt
mit ihnen und es ist unbeschreiblich und
unvorstellbar sie sind bewaffnet und sie
versuchen alles zu tun um irland um ihre
hauptstadt zu verteidigen und ich will
die gelegenheit nutzen von hier aus in
ein gruß auszurichten aus dem freien
berlin in das freie kiew und alles
wünschen dass kiew auf frei bleibt
normalerweise wäre ich gar nicht hier
sondern auch den weg nach moskau nach
inguschetien und nach da gestern das
schließt sich natürlich jetzt sowieso
ausschließlich aber auch deshalb aus
weil wir russland ausgeschlossen haben
aus dem europarat weil ich wäre
eigentlich in der aufgabe des europarats
dort gewesen wir haben russland
ausgeschlossen ich weiß es gab eine
lange debatte darum das war es aber eine
schnelle entscheidung eine entscheidung
in großer einigkeit und sie war
ohne alternative
ich wollte gerade sagen unumkehrbar ich
hoffe nicht ich hoffe dass russland
eines tages zurückkehren kann in den
europarat aber es wird ein langer und
sehr schwerer weg werden
und ehrlich gesagt es hat auch keinen
sinn mehr gemacht das muss ich leider
hier eingestehen weil russland ja nicht
nur nach außen kriegerischen aggressiv
ist sondern auch im inneren alle
menschenrechte verletzt von demokratie
gerade hat jemand gesagt das muss man
dann demokratisch irgendwie putin
abwählen es gibt keine demokratie in
russland das ist alles eine farce was
dort entsprechend stattfindet und es ist
eine schande es ist schlimm zu sehen wie
die menschen in der ukraine leiden wie
sie sterben aber es ist doch auch eine
schande dass putin für diesen absurden
krieg seine eigenen leute verfeuert wenn
man die bilder sieht von jungen soldaten
und soldaten aus russland jetzt auf den
straßen der ukraine sterben bis dann ist
es absurd und dann versündigt sich putin
eben auch an seinem eigenen volk
es ist eben kein kann
gegen russen und russen das ist ein
kampf um freiheit und demokratie
und gerechtigkeit
um das freie europa um menschenrechte
und die ukraine steht an der front
dieses krieges für uns alle letztendlich
will danken für den antrag den es heute
gibt und er gleich verabschiedet wird
weil er deutlich macht dass wir den
europarat nicht alleinlassen russland
scheidet aus es fehlen gelder im
europarat es wäre absurd wenn wir am
ende dafür sorgen würden durch diesen
ausschuss dass der europarat geschwächt
würde im gegenteil es ist das haus der
menschenrechte der demokratie und der
freiheit und das muss jetzt erst recht
gestärkt werden in diesen zeiten
und ich will schließen weil ich hier der
letzte debattenredner heute bin mit
freiheit für die ukraine slava ukraine
vielen dank herr kollege schlage
diese kollegen damit schließlich die
aussprache verbunden mit einem
ausdrücklichen dank an das haus für
diese debatte die dem ernster lage
wirklich angemessen war
wir trauern mit den opfern in der
ukraine aber es trauern auch mit deren
väter in russland um ihre söhne die in
einem sinnlosen angriffskrieg durch
ihren eigenen präsidenten geopfert
worden sind diesen müttern und vätern
geht auch unser mitleid
und ich glaube ich spreche im namen des
ganzen hauses denn wir hoffen dass das
sinnlose sterben ukraine
schnellstmöglich ein ende findet
liebe kolleginnen kollegen willkommen
zur abstimmung über die
entschließungsanträge
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen der
afg aufbruchs
843 wer stimmt für diesen
entschließungsantrag dass sie die
fw-fraktion wer stimmt dagegen das ist
der rest des hauses damit dieser
schließungs antrag abgelehnt
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen der
aufdruck sache 844 wer stimmt für diesen
diesen erschließungs antrag ist erneut
die afg fraktion bestimmt dagegen der
rest des hauses dann ist auch diese
entschließungsantrag abgelehnt entsteht
ein zweiter fraktion die linke aufdrucks
nach 845 bestimmt für die erschließungs
antrag die linke wäre stimmt dagegen
der rest des hauses dann ist auch diese
entschließungsantrag abgelehnt zum
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen spd
cdu csu bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
auf boxer 80 640 liegt eine erklärung
zur abstimmung gemäß § 31 geschäfts und
bundestages vor ich rufe die
entschließungsantrag auf wer stimmt für
diesen entschließungsantrag
das sind die fraktionen aus spd bündnis
90 die grünen fdp cdu csu wer stimmt
gegen diesen entschließungsantrag das
sind die fraktionen der afg und der
linken
wer enthält sich wir haben einen
abgeordneten gaben zwei abgeordnete ein
fraktionsloser und einer aus der afg die
sich enthalten damit ist dieser
entschließungsantrag angenommen die
bequemen kollegen wir sind damit heute
am schluss unserer tagesordnung ich
berufe die nächste sitzung des deutschen
bundestages ein doch mittwoch den 16
märz 2022 13 uhr die sitzung ist
geschlossen